I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hi, Jenna. I feel like we're both full of beans today. Full of beans? Is that mean full of energy? Oh, gassy beans. I guess. I mean, we're not gassy. I'm not gassy. Well, I do have hot feet today, though. My feet are very warm. I don't get hot feet. My feet are always cold. I bought a new pair of shoes. I love them. Look at them. Look
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们正在为您录制独家播客节目《办公室重温之旅》。每周我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并为您讲述只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。你好，安吉拉。嗨，珍娜。我觉得我们俩今天都精力充沛。精力充沛？是满肚子气的意思吗？哦，胀气的豆子。我猜。我的意思是，我们没有胀气。我没有胀气。不过，我今天脚确实很热。我的脚很暖和。我的脚从来不会发热。我的脚总是很冷。我买了一双新鞋。我很喜欢它们。看看它们。看
how cute they are. Oh, they're so cute. Right? But they have like a Sherpa lining in them. Why if you have a tendency for hot feet, would you get shoes with Sherpa? I don't have a tendency for hot feet. I have a tendency for cold feet, but it's a 90-degree day today. But I wanted to wear them because they're so cute. Here's the other thing. They're a half-size too big because they only come in full sizes. So I have to wear a thick sock with a Sherpa lining on a 90-degree day I've got hot feet. All for fashion, y'all. All for fashion. Well, you know me. I know you. Listen, when you look up fashion, athletic fashion, fashion and athletic. It's me. It's you. And this shoe is a fashion-athletic shoe.
它们有多可爱。哦，它们太可爱了。对吧？但它们的里面有一层谢尔帕（羊羔绒）衬里。如果你有脚容易发热的倾向，为什么还要买有羊羔绒的鞋子呢？我没有脚容易发热的倾向。我有脚容易发冷的倾向，但今天是90度的大热天。但我还是想穿它们，因为它们太可爱了。还有一件事。它们大了一个半码，因为它们只有整码。所以我不得不穿着厚袜子，里面还有羊羔绒衬里，在90度的大热天里，我的脚热极了。各位，这一切都是为了时尚。一切为了时尚。好吧，你们了解我。我了解你。听着，当你在字典里查时尚、运动时尚、时尚与运动时。那就是我。就是你。这双鞋就是一双时尚运动鞋。
You know what? I'm going to take a picture of it. It's high fashion. All right. Today we're talking about Blood Drive, Season 5, Episode 18, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Randall Einhorn. It's Valentine's Day. Yeah, this was our Valentine's Day episode. It was also the 90th episode of the office. Wow. That's not even a fast fact. I haven't even gotten to fast facts yet. Do you have a lot of fast facts? I feel like this means you have a lot of fast facts. I have a fun fast fact. What is it? Well, let's do a summary first. You know, I have to go in orderly. Oh, okay. Okay. It is Valentine's Day. And there's a blood drive taking place in the parking lot of the Scranton Business Park.
你知道吗？我要给它拍张照片。这是高级时尚。好了。今天我们来聊聊《献血车》，第五季第18集，由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧，兰德尔·埃因霍恩执导。今天是情人节。是的，这是我们的情人节单集。这也是《办公室》的第90集。哇。这甚至都算不上一个冷知识。我甚至还没讲到冷知识环节呢。你有很多冷知识吗？我觉得这意味着你有很多冷知识。我有一个有趣的冷知识。是什么？好吧，我们先来做个总结。你知道的，我得按顺序来。哦，好吧。好的。今天是情人节。斯克兰顿商务园的停车场里正在举办一场献血活动。
Michael meets a young woman while giving blood, but he passes out before he can get her name and phone number. So he decides to throw a lonely hearts party for the office. Well, he's grumpy because he's single and, you know, he doesn't want to celebrate Valentine's Day. He doesn't. And he certainly doesn't need Jim and Pam and Phyllis and Bob rubbing their couple's lunch in his face. Their couple's love in his face. I don't need love in my face today. That's what Michael was saying. Not me. I want love in my face. What? I don't know. Okay. Fast fact number one. What? You look so excited. Are you still laughing about love in my face? Yeah. Okay. What's fast fact number one? Fast fact number one are some
迈克尔在献血时遇到了一位年轻女子，但在他问出她的名字和电话号码之前，他就晕倒了。于是他决定为办公室举办一个孤单的心派对。好吧，他很暴躁，因为他是单身，而且，你知道的，他不想庆祝情人节。他确实不想。他当然也不需要让吉姆、帕姆、菲利斯和鲍勃把他们的情侣午餐塞到他脸。把他们的情侣之爱塞到他脸上。我今天不需要把爱塞到我脸上。迈克尔就是这么说的。我不是。我想把爱塞到我脸上。什么？我不知道。好吧。冷知识一。什么？你看起来太兴奋了。你还在笑“把爱塞到我脸上”这个梗吗？是的。好吧。冷知识一是什​​么？冷知识一是关于
facts about our blood mobile that was in our parking lot. It reminded me a little bit of like the work bus bus. Yeah. Do they have one bus? They just trick out for everything? No, ma'am. Oh, Randy Cordray told me we used a real blood mobile from the Providence St. Joseph's Hospital in Burbank. We had it for three days. So on Monday, the set dressers went in and they turned it into kind of a more generic looking blood mobile for our purposes. On Tuesday, we did all of our scenes inside the blood mobile and on Wednesday, it was staffed with actual nurses and anyone in the cast and crew could actually donate blood. I remember that because everyone was walking around with a little sticker that said I gave
停在我方停车场的那辆献血车的一些事实。这让我想起了那个工作巴士。是的。他们只有一辆巴士吗？他们只是把一辆车改装成各种用途吗？不是的，女士。哦，兰迪·科德雷告诉我，我们用的是伯班克普罗维登斯圣约瑟夫医院的一辆真正的献血车。我们用了三天。所以周一，布景师进去，为了我们的需要，把它变成了一辆看起来更普通一点的献血车。周二，我们在献血车里拍摄了所有的场景，周三，车里配备了真正的护士，演员和剧组里的任何人实际上都可以捐献血。我记得那是因为每个人都在走来走去，身上贴着一张小贴纸，上面写着我献了
blood and I didn't have one. I felt a little shame. I was on location that day. That's the day we shot the restaurant stuff. So I didn't get to give blood that day either. Well, I went to give blood and they turned me away because of your tininess and your because you have to weigh at least 110 pounds to give blood. It's true. So they turned me away. What? That's the fact. I know. Okay. It's true. No, that is true. It is true. I've never been turned away from giving blood. Well, I still can't. I'm a hearty lady. You're not hearty. Yes, I am. You're what the kids call thick, T-H-I-C-C. By the way, I'm only saying that because someone wrote in one of my comments on Instagram. Oh, Angela is thick
血，而我却没有。我感到有点羞耻。那天我在外景地。那是我们拍摄餐馆戏的那天。所以我那天也没能献血。好吧，我去献血，他们因为你太瘦而拒绝了我，因为你必须体重至少达到110磅才能献血。千真万确。所以他们拒绝了我。什么？这就是事实。我知道。好吧。这是真的。不，这确实是真的。这是真的。我从来没有在献血时被拒绝过。好吧，我还是不能。我是个壮实的女人。你才不壮实呢。不，我是。你就是孩子们所说的丰满，T-H-I-C-C。顺便说一句，我这么说只是因为有人在我的Instagram评论里写了。哦，安吉拉很丰满
and I had to Google it. I think it's a good thing, lady. I think it means we got a little junk in her trunk, but in all the right places. Okay. Well, then I'll take it as a compliment. Well, according to Urban Dictionary, it's a good thing. Good. Yeah. All right. Now it's fast fact number two and I'm just so excited, lady. Okay. Because I looked up the history of blood drives and blood mobiles. You guys, I want you to know a few days ago, Jenna texted me and was like, I'm really excited about my fast fact number two. And I was like, okay, here's the thing. I'm a little bit of kind of a science nerd. You are. Like my favorite book that I read in the last two years is this book called The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks.
，我不得不去谷歌一下。我觉得这是个好词，女士。我想这意思是我们身上有点肉，但都长在了该长的地方。好吧。那我就把它当作赞美了。好吧，根据城市词典，这是个好词。很好。是的。好了，现在是冷知识二，我太兴奋了，女士。好的。因为我查了献血和献血车的历史。伙计们，我想让你们知道，几天前，珍娜给我发短信说：“我对我的冷知识二真的很兴奋。”我就想，好吧，事情是这样的。我有点像个科学书呆子。你是。比如我在过去两年读过的最喜欢的一本书，是一本叫《亨丽埃塔·拉克斯的不朽细胞》的书。
Do you know what it's about? I have no idea. Okay. This woman in 1951, she had a cancer surgery and they took some of her cells. This was like a thing where like you donate, I'm putting that in quotes, your cells for medical research, but it's without your consent. Well, anyway, this woman's cells were so hardy. They are like the basis of all of the most important medical research to this day. Like her cells are why we have a polio vaccine. It's amazing. She's like super human. It's just like her contribution to science is overwhelming. And yet her descendants and her family have never been compensated. Oh. And so the book is fascinating. And my research into blood drives and blood mobiles, it touches on that same part of me that is just fascinated by like
你知道它讲的是什么吗？我完全不知道。好吧。这个女人在1951年做了一次癌症手术，他们取了她的一些细胞。这是一件类似于你捐献的事，我把这个词打上引号，你的细胞用于医学研究，但这是在未经你同意的情况下进行的。不管怎样，这个女人的细胞生命力太顽强了。它们可以说是至今所有最重要的医学研究的基础。比如她的细胞就是我们拥有脊髓灰质炎疫苗的原因。这太神奇了。她就像超人一样。她对科学的贡献简直令人惊叹。然而她的后代和家人从未得到过补偿。哦。所以这本书非常吸引人。我对献血和献血车的调查，触及了我内心深处对
medical discoveries. So are you ready? I wish you could see Jenna right now, you guys. She is so animated. Her hands are moving like she's bending her fingers and she's pointing and then she's reaching to the sky. Go. So in order to talk about blood banking and blood mobiles, we kind of have to start with people's fascination with the idea that blood carries disease. Okay. Now this goes back to the Egyptians. They would do that thing where you would cut yourself and let yourself bleed out your sickness. Okay. So it's like they're on the right track. Like yes, your blood can have things in it that are making you sick, but this is not the solution, right? Right. Right. So right idea, wrong solution. Wrong solution. I feel like there was like a little house on the prairie where
医学发现着迷的那一部分。那你准备好了吗？我真希望你们现在能看到珍娜，伙计们。她太生动了。她的双手在动，就像她在弯曲手指，她指指点点，然后又伸向天空。开始。所以为了讨论血库和献血车，我们必须从人们对“血液携带疾病”这一观念的迷恋开始。好吧。这可以追溯到埃及人。他们会做那种你割伤自己，让血液流尽来治疗疾病的事情。好吧。所以这就像他们走对了方向。就像是的，你的血液里可能有让你生病的东西，但这并不是解决办法，对吧？对。对。所以方向对了，方法错了。方法错了。我觉得就像《草原上的小房子》里那样
they put a bunch of what are those things and leeches all over someone to bleed them out. Same idea. Okay. Okay. So then someone got the idea that what you need is you need like to give the person with the sick blood, healthy blood, a blood transfusion. Yeah. Okay. The first attempted blood transfusion that I could find dates back to 1492. Warning. It's a bit morbid. Okay. Pope Innocent VIII was going into a coma. So they took the blood of three 10-year-old boys and they put it in the Pope's mouth as a transfusion, but all of them died. Well, the Pope and the boys. Yeah. Yeah. Oh man. Well, that is gruesome. Very gruesome. Barbaric. Yes. Slightly scary. Might haunt me. Continue. I'm very sorry. Okay. The first sort of successful
他们把一堆那些东西和水蛭放在某人身上来放血。同样的道理。好吧。好吧。然后有人想出了一个主意，你需要的是给血液有病的人输送健康的血液，即输血。是的。好吧。我能找到的最早的输血尝试可以追溯到1492年。警告。这有点毛骨悚然。好的。教皇英诺森八世当时正陷入昏迷。于是他们取了三个10岁男孩的血，把它倒进教皇嘴里作为输血，但他们都死了。好吧，教皇和男孩们。对。对。天哪。好吧，这太可怕了。非常可怕。野蛮。是的。有点吓人。可能会缠着我。继续。非常抱歉。好吧。第一种算是成功的
blood transfusion was in France in 1667. King Louis XIV's doctor took the blood out of a sheep and he put it into a 15-year-old boy who survived. Now, why? Was the boy sick or was this just an experiment? I think he needed it. Okay. I think it was a medical emergency and they were like, let's try this. Okay. I'm not 100% sure. I probably should have given the disclaimer that this is another segment of A Lady Who Googles. Okay. Okay. Okay. Four to five articles. So then we had a lot of general blood science discovery that happened in the early 1900s. Like, we discovered that there are four main blood types, right? They figured out how to match people together, a donor and a recipient of blood. Do you know your blood type?
输血是在1667年的法国。路易十四国王的医生从一只羊身上抽血，然后把它输给了一个15岁的男孩，他活了下来。现在，为什么？这个男孩生病了还是这只是一场实验？我想他需要它。好吧。我认为这是一次医疗紧急情况，他们当时想，让我们试试这个。好吧。我不百分之百确定。我大概应该加上免责声明，这是“谷歌女士”的另一个环节。好吧。好吧。好吧。四到五篇文章。然后我们在20世纪初进行了很多关于血液科学的普遍发现。比如，我们发现了四种主要的血型，对吧？他们弄清楚了如何将人们匹配在一起，即血液的捐赠者和接受者。你知道你的血型吗？
I don't. I should know because they told me when I had my kids. So when I had Isabel, I found out I was A positive and so is she and so is my mom. Hey, we're all A positive. I always think to myself, oh, remember to look that up so you know your blood type. Oh yeah. It's so fascinating. Okay, go. I think we should put that on our driver's licenses. Our blood type. Yeah. I think that would be smart. I think that's a good idea. So anyway, I'm so sorry. I hope you're interested in this history. I find it fascinating. Stay with me. So now we're going to go to Russia. Okay. Okay. And this doctor in Russia realizes what I need to do is take blood from one person to another person and so they would do these person to person
我不知道。我应该知道，因为我生孩子时他们告诉我了。所以当我生伊莎贝尔时，我发现我是A型阳性，她也是，我妈妈也是。嘿，我们都是A型阳性。我总是对自己说，哦，记得查一下，这样你就知道你的血型了。哦，是的。太迷人了。好的，继续。我觉得我们应该把这个印在驾照上。我们的血型。是的。我觉得这很聪明。我觉得这是个好主意。总之，非常抱歉。我希望你对这段历史感兴趣。我觉得它很迷人。听我说。现在我们要去俄罗斯。好吧。好吧。俄罗斯的这位医生意识到我需要做的是把一个人的血抽出来输给另一个人，所以他们会进行这种人对人的
transfusions. Okay. The problem is that it was really hard to get a giver to a recipient in time, like the convenience, right? Right. So that was working. Person to person blood transfusions were working. It was great, but there was a time factor and there was like a convenience factor. That is when a doctor in Chicago named Bernard Fantas had the idea of getting donors and storing their blood. And this was possible because they learned there was something you could add to blood to keep it from clotting. Okay. So now blood storage was possible and they believe that Bernard Fantas is credited with creating the first blood bank. Okay. Go Bernard. But perhaps the most important contributor to live donor blood drives was Dr. Charles Drew. Remember this name.
输血。好吧。问题是，很难及时把捐赠者送到接受者那里，比如便利性，对吧？对。所以这行得通。人与人之间的输血是行得通的。这很好，但有一个时间因素，还有一个便利因素。就在那时，芝加哥的一位名叫伯纳德·范特斯的医生提出了招募捐献者并储存他们的血液的想法。这是可能的，因为他们得知可以在血液中添加某种东西来防止凝固。好吧。现在血液储存成为可能，他们认为伯纳德·范特斯被认为是建立了第一个血库。好吧。好样的，伯纳德。但也许对活体捐献者献血活动做出最大贡献的是查尔斯·德鲁博士。记住这个名字。
Okay. Dr. Charles Drew. He was an American surgeon and medical researcher. He dedicated his life to researching and improving the techniques for blood storage and blood transfusions. His research is what has contributed to the creation of large scale blood banks. They are the reason why the American Red Cross was able to collect more than 13 million pints of blood during World War II. And it also appears that the blood mobile was the brainchild of Dr. Charles Drew. Dr. Charles Drew. Yes. Yes. Because now, you know, the thing could come to you and get your blood. By the way, January is National Blood Donor Month. It's always a good New Year's resolution and you can find ways to give blood at the Red Cross website. There you go. I loved all of it except
好的。查尔斯·德鲁博士。他是一位美国外科医生和医学研究员。他将一生奉献给研究和改进血液储存和输血技术。他的研究为大规模血库的建立做出了贡献。正是因为他们，美国红十字会在二战期间才能够收集到超过1300万品脱的血液。而且献血车似乎也是查尔斯·德鲁博士的心血结晶。查尔斯·德鲁博士。是的。是的。因为现在，你知道的，那东西可以来找你并抽取你的血液。顺便说一句，一月份是全国献血月。这总是一个很好的新年决心，你可以在红十字会的网站上找到献血的方法。就是这样。我很喜欢这一切，除了
for the beginning part. I know. I'm sorry for the beginning part, but that is the first blood transfusion on record according to the four to five websites that I read. Anyway, read the book, The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks. It's really good. Okay. Also, Dr. Charles Drew. Dr. Charles Drew. We're having a blood drive episode because you created the blood mobile. We couldn't have had one in our parking lot without him. All right. Fast fact number three, we got a lot of mail. People want to know who played the woman giving blood in the truck with Michael. Chelsea D said, I thought the way Michael met that woman at the blood drive is one of the best meat cutes I've ever seen on a TV show. Well, everyone,
开头的那部分。我知道。我很抱歉开头的那部分，但根据我读过的四到五家网站，那是历史上记载的第一例输血。不管怎样，去读读《亨丽埃塔·拉克斯的不朽细胞》这本书吧。真的很好。好的。还有，查尔斯·德鲁博士。查尔斯·德鲁博士。我们制作献血车这一集是因为你创造了献血车。如果没有他，我们的停车场里就不会有献血车。好的。冷知识三，我们收到了很多信件。人们想知道在卡车里和迈克尔一起献血的那个女人是谁。切尔西D说，我觉得迈克尔在献血站遇到那个女人的方式是我在电视节目中见过最棒的偶遇之一。好吧，各位，
she was played by Katie Asselton. She is a delight. I adore her. She's so sweet. We know her. Yes. We're friends with her. You guys, you probably recognize her from the league or togetherness or legion. She's so good in legion. So good. Oh, man. Well, we reached out to her. We did. And she told us how she got her role in the office. Hi, guys. I hope you guys are great. I miss seeing your faces, but I'm thrilled that you reached out getting to work on the office has and will ever be just a real career highlight for me. What a thrill. It was my first big job. So yeah, what a way to start, right? So let me just jump right in to answer Allison Jones, who is a champion of so many of us was a champion of mine. She is
她由凯蒂·阿瑟尔顿饰演。她是个开心果。我崇拜她。她太甜了。我们认识她。是的。我们和她是朋友。你们大家，你们可能从《联盟》、《患难与共》或《军团》中认出她。她在《军团》里演得太好了。太棒了。哦，天哪。好吧，我们联系了她。我们确实联系了。她告诉了我们她是如何得到《办公室》里的角色的。嗨，大家好。希望你们都过得很好。我怀念看到你们的面孔，但我很高兴你们联系了我，能在《办公室》工作一直是也永远是我职业生涯中的一个真正亮点。太激动了。这是我的第一份大工作。所以，是的，以这样的方式开始，对吧？所以让我直奔主题，回答艾莉森·琼斯的问题，她是我们当中许多人的伯乐，也是我的伯乐。她来自
from Maine and I am from Maine and we just have always had that really beautiful connection. But she called me in for this. And, you know, when an audition just clicks and this one felt that way, and it was like one of those things where I was like, oh, man, this like might actually happen. And it did. They bought it. And that it really like started everything for me. I got just instant cred getting to be a part of that show. And I'm just like, what a what a fun, fun first role it was. So cool. You know, I hadn't watched this episode in a long time. And when it got to that scene, I was like, oh, my God, there's Katie. And she is so incredibly charming. Like I want her and Michael to date, you know, they're so cute. Same, Angela. When I saw it, I was like, oh, my gosh, it's Katie.
缅因州，我也来自缅因州，我们之间一直有着非常美好的联系。但她把我叫来试镜。而且，你知道的，当试镜一拍即合时，这一次就给人这种感觉，就像那种我觉得，哦，天哪，这可能真的会发生的事情。结果确实如此。他们买账了。这真的就像为我开启了一切。能成为那部剧的一部分，我立刻获得了名望。我当时就想，这真是一个有趣、有趣的第一份工作。太酷了。你知道的，我很久没有看过这一集了。当看到那个场景时，我心想，哦，天哪，那是凯蒂。她非常有魅力。就像我希望她和迈克尔约会一样，你知道的，他们太可爱了。我也是，安吉拉。当我看到它时，我心想，哦，天哪，那是凯蒂。
And she's an amazing actress. She's also a director. She's directed three films. Her latest film is starring Diane Keaton, Elizabeth Lail and Nicole Byer. It's called Mac and Rita. She's in post production on it now. And I told her that when it comes out, we'll put a shout out in the pod so that people can find it. Yeah, that's a great cast. Well, lady, that is all of my fast facts. Well, I think we should go to break because when we come back, I might need to throw Jim a little shade. Really? Yeah. I can't wait to find out why. I might have something tacky to say. Oh, oh, those are always my favorite messages. What do you mean? You'll like text me and be like, hey, can you call me? I have something tacky to say. And I'm like, oh, I can't wait. And I drop everything.
她是个了不起的女演员。她还是一位导演。她导演了三部电影。她的最新电影由黛安·基顿、伊丽莎白·莱尔和妮可·拜尔主演。它叫《麦克和丽塔》。她现在正在进行后期制作。我告诉她，等它上映时，我们会在播客中大声喊出来，以便大家能找到它。是的，演员阵容太棒了。好吧，女士，这就是我所有的冷知识了。好吧，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我可能需要对吉姆冷嘲热讽一番。真的吗？是的。我迫不及待地想知道为什么。我可能有些俗气的话要说。哦，哦，那些总是我的最爱。什么意思？你总是给我发短信说，嘿，你能给我打电话吗？我有俗气的话要说。我就想，哦，我等不及了。我放下手头的一切。
I have to call Angela. All right, we'll be back. Angela, while you were getting tea during your break, Sam told me something beyond fascinating that I didn't know. It's more news about blood. What? Sam, will you please share? Yeah, they have blood donors and banks just like for humans, but for dogs. Aw. And they do the same thing. They donate little, little pouches of blood. And Sam got to meet a dog that donates his blood once a month at your vet. His name is Ben and he's a golden retriever and he has a little vest with a heart on it. Aw. And he's a very good boy. Oh, that is so sweet. Very good boy. That is like stuff I don't even think about. I know. But of course. Of
我得给安吉拉打电话。好了，我们要回来了。安吉拉，当你在休息时间去喝茶时，萨姆告诉我一些我不知道的超级迷人的事情。这是关于血液的更多消息。什么？萨姆，你能分享一下吗？是的，他们有献血者和血库，就像人类一样，但是是为狗狗准备的。噢。他们做着同样的事情。他们捐献一小包一小包的血。萨姆遇到了一只狗，它每个月在你的兽医那里捐一次血。他的名字叫本，是一只金毛寻回犬，他穿着一件带有心形图案的小背心。噢。他是个好孩子。哦，太甜了。真是个好孩子。这简直是我连想都没想过的事。我知道。但当然。当然
course. All right, should we get started? Let's get started. Guess what? What? There is a rep from Techstar who says there's a whole new operating system for the phones. And he could like meet with Michael Scott, but Michael Scott's never around. I wonder why. Well, Pam says if they get this new phone system that allows the caller to contact the salespeople directly, that's basically 95% of her job. So she is clearly never letting this guy meet Michael because she doesn't want to lose her job. I don't think Michael would ever let her go. I just want to say Pam, you don't have to worry because Michael thinks you're his personal secretary. Yeah. So even if you got that phone system, you know what it would mean? She'd probably have to spend more time with Michael.
。好了，我们要开始了吗？我们开始吧。你猜怎么着？什么？有一个来自Techstar的代表说，电话有一个全新的操作系统。他可以和迈克尔·斯科特会面，但迈克尔·斯科特从来都不在。我想知道为什么。好吧，帕姆说，如果他们引入这个新电话系统，允许来电者直接联系销售人员，这基本上占了她工作的95%。所以她显然绝不会让这个人见迈克尔，因为她不想失去工作。我不认为迈克尔会让她走。我只想说帕姆，你不用担心，因为迈克尔认为你是他的私人秘书。是的。所以即使你得到了那个电话系统，你知道这意味着什么吗？她可能得花更多时间陪迈克尔。
You wouldn't be as busy. So he'd be like, Pam, come in my office. It's true. I have to say I appreciate when a person answers the phone when I call a business. Me too. I wouldn't like that new phone system. I like to get a human. I do too. I'm chatty. Well, I want you to know at 49 seconds, there are a few messages taped to Pam's desk. I saw the same thing. You did? Okay. I want to know who Nick is. Oh, yeah. There's like a message on a pin star post-it note, which by the way, pin star was a bank branch in Pennsylvania. Love those details. Nick in office all day. Yeah. That's what the note said. I mean, who is Nick? Well, I know who Nick will be. Nick will be our IT guy. Nick will be? No, Nick will be our IT guy. No, I'm sorry. That just made
你就不会那么忙了。所以他会说，帕姆，进我办公室来。确实如此。我得说，当我给企业打电话时，如果有人接听电话，我会很感激。我也是。我不会喜欢那个新电话系统。我喜欢找个真人。我也是。我很健谈。好吧，我想让你知道，在49秒的时候，帕姆的桌上贴着几条便条。我也看到了。你看到了？好吧。我想知道尼克是谁。哦，是的。有一条留言贴在一个Pin Star的便利贴上，顺便说一句，Pin Star是宾夕法尼亚州的一个银行分支机构。真喜欢这些细节。尼克全天在办公室。是的。纸条上就是这么写的。我的意思是，尼克是谁？好吧，我知道尼克会是谁。尼克将成为我们的IT人员。尼克会是吗？不，尼克将成为我们的IT人员。不，对不起。这只是让我
me laugh. Okay. So we don't know who Nick is, but someday in the future, we're going to have an IT guy named Nick. Yes. Also, Jenna, was that your grocery list? It was my grocery list. I know you're getting green tea. And pomegranate seeds and pine nuts. What were you, what was happening? Okay. There was the salad I really liked at the time and it had pomegranate seeds and pine nuts in it. When I saw that sticky note, I was like, oh my gosh, I should make that salad again. I loved it. I thought I recognized your handwriting. I was like, that's Jenna's grocery list. It was. Did you also notice there is a photo of me and John on my desk? We're standing up. Up. This was our engagement photo. Yeah. We did this special photo shoot. It was the day that
笑了。好吧，所以我们不知道尼克是谁，但未来的某一天，我们将拥有一个名叫尼克的IT人员。还有，珍娜，那是你的购物清单吗？那是我的购物清单。我知道你要买绿茶。还有石榴籽和松子。你当时在干什么？好吧。当时我真的很喜欢一种沙拉，里面有石榴籽和松子。当我看到那张便利贴时，我心想，哦，天哪，我应该再做一次那个沙拉。我很喜欢它。我以为我认得你的笔迹。我当时想，那是珍娜的购物清单。确实是的。你有没有注意到我的桌上还有一张我和约翰的照片？我们是站着的。站着的。这是我们的订婚照。是的。我们拍了这组特别的照片。那是那天
we shot at Jim's parents' house when he's showing me around. We brought this extra set of clothes and we posed in the backyard. Jim has one on his desk too. He does, but on his desk, I'm sitting on his lap. Right. And on yours, you're standing. Yes. So this was, I think they went out for this Valentine's Day episode, our engagement photos. Jim's going to come to Pam's rescue. He's like, Michael Scott here. And then this next bit was so funny. And Jenna, you were so excited to be part of it. I remember you were like, so excited because, you know, Michael walks out and it's like, Hey, and Jim is like, Jimbo. And instead of Michael being like, what are you talking about? He's instantly like, Oh, what are we doing? We're doing a bit. We're doing a bit. I'm so excited.
我们在吉姆父母家拍的，当时他正带我四处参观。我们带了这套额外的衣服，在后院摆了姿势。吉姆的桌上也有一张。他确实有一张，但在他的桌上，我是坐在他腿上的。没错。而在你的桌上，你是站着的。是的。所以这是，我想他们是为这个情人节单集而拍的，我们的订婚照。吉姆要去解救帕姆了。他说，迈克尔·斯科特在这。然后接下来的这一段太搞笑了。珍娜，你当时特别兴奋能参与其中。我记得你当时说，超级兴奋，因为，你知道的，迈克尔走出来说，嘿，然后吉姆说，吉姆博。迈克尔没有说“你在说什么呢”，而是立刻说，“哦，我们在做什么？我们在演段子。我们在演段子。”我太兴奋了。
And then all of a sudden, everyone's Fonzie. I know. It was really fun. We were laughing on the day when we shot that. It was so fun to do those. I feel like I should let you know that the phone tech rep was played by Rob Brownstein. He looked familiar to me. Well, he's been on Monk. He was also on the short-lived Law and Order Los Angeles. Oh, he's been on Breaking Bad and on Mad Men. But Lady. What? His latest movie. Yeah. Which has not come out yet. Oh, no. No, wait, wait, wait. Is it John Wick? No. Oh, it's called Hummingbird. Oh, I'll go see it. It's a sci-fi movie. Listen to the tagline. I'm in. When beloved telepathic superhero Hummingbird, also known as Lola Laxman, is left for dead after a major battle, she makes a deal with the devil to save her life.
然后突然之间，所有人都变成了方济。我知道。拍摄的那天我们一直在笑。拍这些真的太有趣了。我觉得我应该告诉你，那个电话技术代表是由罗布·布朗斯坦饰演的。他对我来说看起来很面熟。好吧，他演过《神探阿蒙》。他还出演过短命的《法律与秩序：洛杉矶》。哦，他演过《绝命毒师》和《广告狂人》。但是，女士。什么？他的最新电影。是的。还没上映呢。哦，不。不，不，不。是《疾速追杀》吗？不。哦，它叫《蜂鸟》。哦，我要去看。这是一部科幻电影。听听宣传语。算我一个。我们俩都算上。是的。我们要去看《蜂鸟》。我要和你一起拍一部科幻片。听着，你知道吗？你可以扮演那个走进来为事情提供科学依据的科学实验室技术员女士。
Sign me up. Sign us both up. Yeah. We're going to go see Hummingbird. I'm going to be in a sci-fi with you. Listen, you know what? You can be the science lab tech lady that comes in and gives the science behind the thing. Okay. You know what I would love to be in is a movie like Outbreak. What's it called? Outbreak. No. No. Not that movie with Kurt Russell. The thing. Ew. The thing. Ew. Yeah. Gross. Have you seen it? I feel like I saw part of it and I had to bail. It's so good. The practical effects in that movie are outstanding. All right. Should we get into this episode? We should. There is a Valentine's Day blood drive happening, as you guys know. And I want to point out that the Scranton Business Park went
好吧。你知道我很想参演什么电影吗？像《极度恐慌》那样的电影。它叫什么？《极度恐慌》。不。不。不是库尔特·拉塞尔演的那部电影。《怪形》。呃。《怪形》。呃。是的。太恶心了。你看过吗？我觉得我看了一部分就看不下去了。太棒了。那部电影里的实用特效太出色了。好了。我们应该开始聊这一集了吗？我们应该。如你们所知，情人节献血活动正在进行中。我要指出的是，斯克兰顿商务园的装饰
all out with decorations. They really did. I mean, there is a Happy Valentine's Day banner. There's three red cupid shooting heart arrows, big hearts with love messages all on the walls. There's like a vase with like little plastic hearty things on the counter. There's a giant heart on the elevator doors that opens when they get in. Who is decorating the Scranton Business Park? I have a theory. What's your theory? I think it's Phyllis. She's married to Bob Vance. He's one of the five families. You might be right, since she can't be the Dunder Mifflin Party Planner anymore. Yeah. She's like, Bob, I've got a bin of hearts and cupids. I can put them around the lobby. I love Phyllis' voice when she's talking to Bob. Well, we also find out that
真是花尽了心思。确实如此。我是说，有一个“情人节快乐”的横幅。有三个红色的丘比特在发射心形箭，墙上贴满了带有爱意信息的大红心。柜台里有一个插着塑料心形小物件的花瓶。他们进去时打开的电梯门上有一个巨大的心形图案。到底是谁在装扮斯克兰顿商务园？我有一个理论。你的理论是什么？我觉得是菲利斯。她嫁给了鲍勃·范斯。他是五大家族之一。你可能是对的，既然她不能再当邓德米夫林的派对策划人了。是的。她会说，鲍勃，我有一箱心形饰品和丘比特。我可以把它们挂在大堂四周。我很喜欢菲利斯跟鲍勃说话时的声音。好吧，我们还发现
it is Jim and Pam's first and only Valentine's Day as fiance's. Did you see at two minutes 41 seconds that Pam's got some real cute dangle pink earrings and a sassy ponytail? I love the sassy ponytail. Me too. I do love a sassy ponytail. Kelly has received a Valentine from a secret admirer. She opens it up. It says roses are red, violets are blue. It's time for your dental cleaning and maybe a checkup too. I want to say that this resonated with me. I have been Kelly where I've gotten what looks like a personal holiday card and then it's from like my dry cleaner. Yeah. You know what I mean? Or a Valentine's Day card that I think, oh, oh, or birthday. Do you ever get the birthday greetings from like? From like, you get it like a birthday greeting from
这是吉姆和帕姆作为未婚夫的第一个也是唯一一个情人节。你在2分41秒时看到帕姆戴着非常可爱的粉红色流苏耳环，还扎着俏皮的马尾辫吗？我喜欢那个俏皮的马尾辫。我也是。我真的很喜欢俏皮的马尾辫。凯莉收到了一位倾慕者的情人节卡片。她打开一看。上面写着玫瑰是红色的，紫罗兰是蓝色的。是时候洗牙了，也许还要做个检查。我想说的是，这引起了我的共鸣。我也经历过凯莉那种情况，收到看起来像是个人节日贺卡的信，结果却是干洗店寄来的。是的。你知道我的意思吗？或者是一张情人节卡片，我以为，哦，哦，或者是生日卡。你有没有收到过这样的生日祝福？来自，比如，你收到来自
your gynecologist. Right. Exactly. At Christmas, you know, a lot of businesses will send out like a company Christmas card. Yeah. I tape them right up with all my family and friends Christmas cards. It just tickles me to be like, oh, there's like my friends family. They're so cute and there's my aunt and uncle and there's my air conditioning company. Yep. Right there with a little wreath over the giant air conditioning unit. It goes up on the wall, guys, if you send it to me. This is true about you. Should we talk about Pam's beautiful Valentine's Day floral arrangement? Oh, we shall. And I'm putting on my glasses for this conversation. Wow. At three minutes and three seconds, we get a real nice shot of this flower arrangement
你的妇科医生的生日祝福。没错。没错。在圣诞节，你知道的，很多企业会寄出公司圣诞卡。是的。我把它们和所有家人朋友的圣诞卡直接贴在一起。这真让我觉得好笑，心想，哦，看，那是我的朋友一家。他们太可爱了，那是我的叔叔阿姨，那是我的空调公司。没错。就在那个挂着花环的巨大空调机旁边。如果你寄给我，它就会上墙的，伙计们。关于你，这确实是真的。我们该聊聊帕姆美丽的情人节花艺了吧？哦，我们会的。我为了这个对话戴上了我的眼镜。哇。在3分03秒的时候，我们得到了一个非常精彩的特写镜头，拍的是吉姆送给帕姆的那束花
that Jim gave Pam. And now I'm about to be tacky. Oh, okay. Here it is. I had a friend growing up who worked at our local flower shop. She told me that carnations are the cheapest flower and they use them to fill out arrangements. And another cheap flower they use are daisies. So if you want to go cheap, you get carnations and daisies. Jim's Valentine flowers are all carnations and daisies, I'm just saying. I noticed it as well. So I looked in the script. I wanted to see if there was a script note about Jim's flower arrangement to Pam. I want to hear it because I have a theory that I will prove. I think I can prove it. Okay. Here is what the script said. There was a note. There is a small bouquet of non-rose flowers
。现在我要开始挑刺了。哦，好吧。就是这样。我从小有个朋友在当地的花店工作。她告诉我康乃馨是最便宜的花，他们用它们来填充花艺。他们用的另一种便宜的花是雏形。所以如果你想省钱，你就会买康乃馨和雏形。吉姆的情人节鲜花全都是康乃馨和雏形，我只是说说而已。我也注意到了。所以我查了剧本。我想看看剧本里有没有关于吉姆送给帕姆的花艺的备注。我想听听，因为我有一个理论，我能证明它。我想我能证明这一点。好吧。剧本上是这么写的。有一个备注。帕姆的桌上有一小束非玫瑰花。
on Pam's desk. Okay. Well, I think Phil Shea from Props ran with this because later in the episode when they go to the fancy restaurant with Bob and Phyllis, this same arrangement is on all the tables. Really? Yes. And if you look up cheap flowers for big events, carnations and daisies, if you have an event like a wedding or whatever, they help fill out the arrangements. So I think Phil was like, okay, great. I can get this small bouquet of this same arrangement that I'm doing for the dinner at the restaurant. Yeah. So in Jim's defense, I don't know, maybe it helped out our props department. Well, also have you know, in this same scene at three minutes and 17 seconds, my grocery list is gone. So we obviously shot this on a different day and I've been shopping now. So
好吧。嗯，我觉得道具组的菲尔·谢伊顺着这个思路发挥了，因为在剧集后面的部分，当他们和鲍勃和菲利斯去那家高档餐厅时，同样的插花摆满了所有的桌子。真的吗？是的。如果你去查大型活动用的便宜花卉，康乃馨和雏形，如果你办婚礼或其他什么活动，它们可以帮助填满花艺。所以我想菲尔当时想，好吧，太好了。我可以弄到一小束和我为餐厅晚宴准备的同样的插花。是的。所以为吉姆辩护一下，我不知道，也许这帮了我们的道具组一个忙。好吧，你可知在同一场景的3分17秒，我的购物清单不见了。所以我们显然是在不同的一天拍摄的，我已经去买过东西了。所以
in case you were worried, I got all my stuff. Michael does not like the flowers. No. He's not a fan. He puts them on the floor. He doesn't want to see them. I was like, you know what? I get that he doesn't want to see them. The floor, couldn't he just like put them on like on one of those tables behind her? I don't know. He wouldn't be able to see them. Well, he goes up to Jim and he says, I need to have a word with you. And he says that today is a very difficult day for many people in the office and that Pam and Jim's sexy vibes are creating a hostile work environment. This whole conversation made me laugh so hard. First of all, it's kind of in hushed tones, you know? And they're saying ridiculous things in hushed tones. That was always really hard for me. Yeah. And when you
如果你担心的话，我已经买齐了东西。迈克尔不喜欢这些花。不。他不是粉丝。他把它们放在地板上。他不想看到它们。我当时就想，你知道吗？我懂他为什么不想看到它们。放在地板上，难道他就不能把它们放在她身后的那些桌子上吗？我不知道。他还是看不到。好吧，他走到吉姆面前说，我有话要跟你说。他说今天对办公室里的许多人来说是非常艰难的一天，帕姆和吉姆的性感磁场创造了一个充满敌意的工作环境。这段对话让我笑得前仰后合。首先，它是压低了声音进行的，你知道吗？他们压低声音说着荒谬的话。这对我来说总是很难。是的。当你说到
were like, Michael, you do not get to be in our relationship. Lady, I wrote that down because I remember making a choice to say that as if it's not the first time I've had to explain that to Michael. It was really good. I wanted it to have history. It did. It really paid off. Well, we had a fan question from Maddie L who says, when Michael asks Jim to have a word with him, he starts to stand up as if he's going to head to Michael's office, but then awkwardly sits back down when Michael chooses to sit on Jim's desk instead. Was this improvised? I think it was. I looked in the script to see if there was any stage direction. Yeah, there wasn't, except that it clearly says they don't move into Michael's office. They stay at Jim's desk. So I think that feels like something
，迈克尔，你可不能介入我们的关系。女士，我把它记下来了，因为我记得当时做出的选择是说出这句话，就好像这不是我第一次向迈克尔解释这件事一样。真的很好。我希望它有历史感。确实有。真的得到了回报。好吧，我们有一个来自马蒂L的粉丝问题，他说，当迈克尔让吉姆跟他说句话时，他站了起来，好像要往迈克尔的办公室走去，但当迈克尔选择坐在吉姆的桌子上时，他又尴尬地坐了回去。这是即兴发挥吗？我觉得是的。我在剧本里找过，看看有没有任何舞台调度。是的，没有，除了剧本明确指出他们没有搬进迈克尔的办公室。他们留在吉姆的桌子旁。所以我觉得这感觉像是
that John and Steve probably found in the moment. It's very funny. 100%. And I feel like those guys, you know, we've talked about this a lot. By this time, everyone knew their characters so well. So those tops and bottoms of a scene, you could kind of play around a little bit. And it looked like them just having fun. It's time to talk about Dwight. I feel like Dwight. How do I say this? I feel like this episode really shows so much of who Dwight is. There's deleted scenes where he talks about the blood mobile being a vampire magnet after dark. He's ready for anything and everything, you know? Yes. And he has a lot of stuff to share about how his body can do things. Yes. The nurse is trying to take blood, but she can't find a vein. Well, you know why? He's hidden
约翰和史蒂夫当时即兴想出来的。非常搞笑。100%是的。我觉得那些家伙，你知道的，我们讨论过很多次。到这个时候，每个人对自己的角色都非常了解。所以一个场景的开头和结尾，你可以稍微玩一下。这看起来就像他们只是在玩乐。是时候谈谈德怀特了。我觉得德怀特。我该怎么说呢？我觉得这一集真的很能展现德怀特是怎样的人。有被删减的片段，他在其中谈到献血车是天黑后的吸血鬼磁铁。他时刻准备着应对一切，你知道的？是的。而且他有很多关于他的身体能做哪些事情的信息要分享。是的。护士试图抽血，但找不到血管。好吧，你知道为什么吗？他把它藏
it from her. And when he's ready, he's gonna pop it on out for her. Then he has a talking head where he tells us he can also retract his penis up into himself. Yeah. He says, I train my major blood vessels to retract into my body on command. Also, I can retract my penis up into itself. We had a fan question from Robin T. Robin, go. Dwight's lines about retracting his blood vessels and penis is one of my favorite quotes from the entire show. It is so absolutely absurd and hilarious and so very Dwight. I want to know everything about this line. Was it scripted? How hard was it to get through? I'll tell you, it was scripted, but this was an alternate talking head. This is not the one that appeared in our shooting draft. So I wasn't there when they shot
起来不让她看到。等他准备好了，他就会为她弹出来。然后他有一个独白镜头，告诉我们他还可以把自己的阴茎缩回体内。是的。他说，我训练我的主要血管按指令缩回我的体内。此外，我还能够把我的阴茎缩回它自己体内。我们有一个来自罗宾T的粉丝问题。罗宾，请讲。德怀特关于缩回血管和阴茎的台词是我整部剧中最喜欢的台词之一。这实在是太荒谬、太搞笑、太德怀特了。我想了解关于这句台词的一切。是剧本写的吗？演下来有多难？我告诉你，这是剧本写的，但这是一个备选的独白。这不是出现在我们拍摄剧本里的那个。所以我拍的时候不在场，但我必须想象演下来一定非常困难。好吧，轮到迈克尔献血了，伙计们。
it, but I have to imagine it was very difficult to get through. Well, it's Michael's turn to give blood, guys. Wow, that's a big needle, he says. Are you squeamish around needles? I can give blood. I don't get faint or anything, but I don't like to watch it. Yeah. I don't like to see the needle go in my arm. I don't like to see the bag fill up, but I don't like it faint or weird around blood. Yeah. Yeah. If someone's bleeding, it doesn't make me faint. Yeah, same. Same. Okay. Michael, on the other hand, is very nervous, but luckily there's a lovely young woman also giving blood, and they start joking around. Yes. We asked Katie about this scene. I wanted to know, did she do any research into the process of giving blood and all of that? And here's what she had to
哇，好大一根针，他说。你对针头晕血吗？我可以献血。我不会晕厥什么的，但我不想看它。是的。我不想看针扎进我的手臂。我不想看到血袋装满，但我不会对血感到晕厥或奇怪。是的。是的。如果有人流血，不会让我晕厥。是的，一样。一样。好的。迈克尔呢，非常紧张，但幸运的是，还有一个可爱的年轻女性也在献血，他们开始开玩笑了。是的。我们问了凯蒂关于这个场景的事。我想知道，她在献血的过程中做过什么研究吗？以下是她的说法。
say. I didn't do any research for this role, but I didn't need to because my character was just nervous and pleasant, and I didn't have to dig super deep to access those emotions. But the funny, I do have a very funny anecdote about being nervous or my character being nervous is that my first line was me just laughing nervously and saying, I'm so sorry. I'm so nervous. And Steve, Steve kept cutting, and he would be like, Oh, no, it's okay. We'll go again. We'll go again. And finally, I was just like, I think it's my line. I think that's what I'm supposed to say. But that has always made me laugh. And of course, yes, I was thrilled to work with Steve to get that, to get the show was its own triumph. But then to have my scene be with him
我没有为这个角色做任何研究，但我不需要这样做，因为我的角色只是紧张而愉快，我不需要深入挖掘就能体会到那些情绪。但是，有趣的是，我确实有一个非常有趣的轶事，关于紧张或者说我的角色感到紧张，那就是我的第一句台词就是紧张地笑着用说，我很抱歉。我太紧张了。而史蒂夫，史蒂夫一直喊停，他会说，哦，不，没关系。我们再来一次。我们再来一次。最后，我只是觉得，我想这是我的台词。我想这就是我应该说的。但这总是让我发笑。当然，是的，能和史蒂夫合作我非常激动，能拍这部剧本身就是一次胜利。但能和他在同一个场景里演戏
was just like, I was over the moon. I love that story about Steve because he was such a caretaker like that. He would want our guest actors to feel really comfortable. And you know, he'd be like, Oh, no, it's okay. We'll start again. We'll wait till you're comfortable. Like, no, it's actually my line. I would also be relieved if the first time I ever had to be in a scene with Steve, I got to just laugh nervously and say I was nervous. Yes, because it would be so truthful. Such an honest moment. Yeah. There's a third person in this scene. It's the nurse. She was great. I wondered if she was a real blood mobile nurse, since that was a real blood mobile. Yeah. And she seemed kind of no nonsense, like very comfortable there. Well, she was in fact an actress.
简直就像，我当时高兴极了。我很喜欢关于史蒂夫的那个故事，因为他就是这么一个体贴的人。他会希望我们的客串演员感到真正的舒适。你知道的，他会说，哦，不，没关系。我们重新开始。我们等到你舒服为止。不，其实这是我的台词。如果我第一次和史蒂夫演对手戏时，只需要紧张地笑笑并说我很紧张，我也会松一口气的。是的，因为那会是如此真实。如此诚实的时刻。是的。这个场景里有第三个人。就是那个护士。她很棒。我想知道她是不是真正的献血车护士，既然那是辆真正的献血车。是的。而且她看起来一点也不拖泥带水，在那里非常自在。好吧，她其实是个演员。
Her name is Julie Ramallah. She has not been on Monk or Law & Order, but she was on several episodes of The Young and the Restless, as well as many movies and TV shows. Well, Michael's going to make the mistake of looking at his blood bag. He freaks out a little and he says to her, tell me a story, say something, distract me. And she says he's cute. And he's, I think, so happy. And then he shears that he didn't eat for three days because he was so nervous about giving blood and he passes out. Yes. We had a fan question. Many, many people wanted to know, how do we do these scenes of people giving blood? Some people wanted to know, did they actually give blood? No. Oh my goodness. No. Not in the episode. Yes. The next day,
她的名字叫朱莉·拉马拉。她没有演过《神探阿蒙》或《法律与秩序》，但她出演过好几集的《年轻和骚动不安的一代》，以及许多电影和电视节目。好吧，迈克尔犯了个错误，去看自己的血袋。他有点抓狂，对她说，给我讲个故事，说点什么，分散一下我的注意力。她说他很帅。我想他高兴坏了。然后他承认自己三天没吃东西了，因为献血太紧张而晕倒了。是的。我们有一个粉丝问题。许多许多人想知道，我们是如何拍摄这些人们献血的场景的？有些人想知道，他们真的献血了吗？没有。哦，天哪。没有。不是在剧集中。是的。第二天，
but not while we were filming. The next day with trained professionals and not actors pretending to take blood. Correct. I found out how they make fake blood. Oh, thanks to Randy Cordray. How do they do it? All right. It's a combination of water, food coloring, and you're not going to believe it. One more thing. Wait, wait, wait. You'll never guess. Wait, wait, wait. I want to try a guess. You can eat it. I thought you could eat it. I was going to say like Jello. Nestle's quick. Oh. Yeah. That thickens it a little, I guess. Yeah. So our blood was all made by our special effects team led by Ron Neri. Had to make fake blood that day. Fake blood. Well, I thought the reveal of Hank when Michael comes to the best moments I laughed so hard. It was so perfect.
但不是在我们拍摄的时候。第二天是由训练有素的专业人士而不是假装抽血的演员来做的。没错。我发现了他们是怎么制作假血的。哦，多亏了兰迪·科德雷。他们是怎么做到的？好的。这是水、食用色素的组合，你绝对不会相信。还有一件事。等等，等等。你永远也猜不到。等等，等等。我想猜一下。你可以吃。我以为你能吃。我本想说是果冻。雀巢快溶巧克力粉。哦。是的，我想这会让它变得浓稠一点。是的。所以我们的血都是由罗恩·内里领导的特效团队制作的。那天必须制作假血。假血。好吧，当迈克尔去找汉克时，汉克的出场让我觉得是我笑得最厉害的时刻之一。太完美了。
And then he calls the nurse a waitress. He's like so out of it. And he finds her glove. He does. And this starts his whole mission to find her. To return the glove. Yeah. Like Cinderella's Slipper. I know. It's really cute. We have one more clip from Katie where she just shares her memories of her time on the show. I asked her, anything stick out to you and Angela, wait until you hear what she says. Oh, I can't wait. I don't remember a ton of details about my time on set, except for that you guys were on your last day of like a very, very, very long cycle of shooting and everyone was just dead tired and just ready for hiatus. So that is what I remember. But they were lovely. Everyone was great. But just like the talk was
然后他把护士叫成女服务员。他当时神志不清。他找到了她的手套。是的。这开启了他寻找她的整个任务。为了归还手套。是的。就像灰姑娘的水晶鞋。我知道。真的很可爱。我们还有一段凯蒂的视频片段，她在其中分享了她对在剧组时光的回忆。我问她，有什么事让你印象深刻吗？安吉拉，等着听她说什么吧。哦，我等不及了。我对在片场的时光没有什么具体的记忆，除了你们当时正在经历非常、非常、非常漫长的拍摄周期的最后一天，每个人都筋疲力尽，只想迎来假期。这就是我的记忆。但他们很可爱。每个人都很好。但大家谈论的焦点
all about how this hiatus was just so needed. So that's what I remember that and that you guys moved so quickly. It was like the fastest. I don't even know if I got lunch that day. Like I showed up. I did my scene and I'm pretty sure you guys banged me out and I didn't even get a free lunch. All right. This was, remember early on, we had to do 18 episodes in a row so that we could create that hiatus for Steve to go do a movie. Yeah. This was that 18th episode. We were so wiped. Yep. 18 weeks of 12 to 14 hour days. Yeah. And you guys, you know, when you have that stretch of work where you leave work and it's dark out and then you come back to work and it's still dark out, you know what I mean? Cause you're there so early. Yeah. And you're just like, and you sort
全都是这个假期是多么急需。所以这就是我的记忆，还有就是你们拍得太快了。就像是最快的。我甚至不知道那天我有没有吃午餐。就像我出现。我拍了我的场景，我很确定你们把我快刀斩乱麻地拍完了，我甚至连一顿免费午餐都没吃上。好了。这是，还记得早期吗，我们必须连续拍18集，以便为史蒂夫腾出假期去拍电影。是的。这就是那第18集。我们累垮了。是的。每周工作12到14小时，连轴转18周。是的。而且你们知道的，当你经历那种工作阶段时，你离开工作时天已经黑了，然后你来上班时天还是黑的，你知道我的意思吗？因为你到得很早。是的。然后你会，你
of all look at each other and joke and be like, see you in a few hours. There's a whole thing now. It's called clopping. And it's a lot of people who work in the service industry or in the food industry where you have to close the restaurant and then like a few hours later, you have to open it. Yeah. Clopping. Clopping. Well, we were in the clopping phase. We were. That is hilarious to me because I do remember like when we would wrap after a big stretch like that, I would get like a cold. I would get sick. We talked about that. Yeah. Right now we were about to all get sick. Yeah. Basically. And Katie clocked it and has remembered it all these years later. That's how tired we were. We were so tired. Next up is a scene I'm dying to talk about. It's in the
们俩看着对方开玩笑说，几小时后见。现在有一个全新的词。这叫“两头黑”。这是许多在服务行业或餐饮业工作的人的真实写照，他们必须打烊关门，然后几个小时后又得开门营业。是的。“两头黑”。“两头黑”。好吧，我们当时就在“两头黑”的阶段。我们确实是。这对我来说太搞笑了，因为我确实记得，在经历了一段这样的大工作量之后杀青时，我会得感冒。我会生病。我们谈论过这个。是的。现在我们都快要生病了。是的。基本上。而凯蒂注意到了这一点，并且多年后仍然记得。这就是我们当时有多累。我们太累了。接下来是一个我极其渴望讨论的场景。它在
conference room. Kelly and Meredith are decorating for the Lonely Hearts Party. Is this a good time to talk about how Meredith is wearing the vest again? Yes. The sweater vest. It is making its second appearance in the series pretty quickly because it was just in the duel. Yes. This is the vest that I wore to a press event with John Krasinski. And by the way, it was not Betsy Johnson. It was Nanette LePore. Fancy. And Meredith loves it clearly and is wearing it again. They were really, I think, rubbing it in my face. I take it personally. I'm kidding. Well, there's something happening now that I as an actor am super jealous of because Jim and Pam are going to go to frickin lunch with Bob and Phyllis. Jenna, I would have loved to been there. That looked
会议室里。凯莉和梅雷迪思正在为孤单的心派对做装饰。现在是时候讨论梅雷迪思为什么又穿着那件背心了吗？是的。毛衣背心。它在剧中的第二次出场相当快，因为它刚刚在决斗那一集出现过。是的。这就是我和约翰·克拉辛斯基一起出席新闻活动时穿的背心。顺便说一句，那不是贝姬·约翰逊。那是Nanette Lepore。真时髦。梅雷迪思显然很喜欢它，而且又把它穿上了。我觉得他们真的，是在我脸上摩擦。我得罪了吗？我开玩笑呢。好吧，现在发生了一件作为演员的我超级嫉妒的事情，因为吉姆和帕姆要去跟鲍勃和菲利斯吃该死的午餐。珍娜，我当时多希望能去啊。看起来
like so much fun. And I love it. It's like the thing we talk about when random characters get thrown together. What's going to happen? What's the chemistry? I lived for every scene. And there was so much more in the script. And there's more in the deleted scenes. Phyllis and I were so excited for the storyline. We're the two St. Louis gals. Yeah. And we got to have this whole day of shooting together. We got to talk about bowling. Yes. We had a fan question from Joe S. Where were the restaurant scenes for the double date filmed? I will tell you. They were filmed at a real restaurant called Bar Sack Brazier. It was on Lancashire Boulevard in North Hollywood. We filled the restaurant with background performers who were pretending to be servers and diners. We had the
太有趣了。我太喜欢了。就像我们谈论的那样，当随机角色被凑在一起时。会发生什么？会有什么化学反应？我为每一个场景而活。剧本里其实还有更多内容。被删减的片段里也有更多。我和菲利斯对这个剧情兴奋极了。我们是两个圣路易斯老乡。是的。我们得有一整天的时间一起拍摄。我们可以聊保龄球。是的。我们有一个来自乔S的粉丝问题。双人约会的餐厅场景是在哪里拍摄的？我来告诉你。它们是在一家名叫Bar Sack Brazier的真实餐厅拍摄的。它位于北好莱坞的兰开夏大道。我们在餐厅里塞满了假装是服务员和食客的背景演员。我们占有了这家
restaurant for half a day. It is no longer in business, but that's where we were. And we ate their real food. Well, if you look at the tables there, you're going to see Jim's bouquet of flowers to Pam on every table. I'll do a side by side in our stories. And I want to ask you, Jenna, about the scene with the bowling. Okay. All right. So Bob says everyone here who's bowled to 280, please raise your hand. And you guys are like super impressed. Yeah. What's the highest bowling number? 300. Oh my gosh. That's a big deal. I don't know a lot about bowling. I don't know much about bowling. Yes. 300 is if you get a strike in every frame. Wowzers. Okay. Well, there was a whole other storyline where clearly the writers wanted Jim and Pam to be impressed by how cool Bob and
餐厅半天时间。它现在已经不营业了，但那就是我们当时所在的地方。我们吃了他们真正的食物。好吧，如果你看看那里的桌子，你会发现在每一张桌子上都有吉姆送给帕姆的那束花。我会在我们的故事中做一个对比图。我想问你，珍娜，关于保龄球的那个场景。好的。好吧。所以鲍勃说，这里所有保龄球打过280分的人，请举手。你们超级印象深刻。是的。保龄球的最高分是多少？300。哦，天哪。那可是件大事。我对保龄球了解不多。我对保龄球了解不多。是的。如果你每一局都全中，那就是300分。哇哦。好吧，还有一个完整的故事情节，编剧们显然希望吉姆和帕姆对鲍勃和菲利斯有多酷留下深刻印象。
Phyllis were. There was a whole other scene where you guys talk about how you went to Dave Matthews Band. Yes. I remember shooting it and that they had great seats and that Phyllis like went backstage and all this stuff. Yeah. We're like, oh my gosh, Bob and Phyllis are kind of cool. And then they excuse themselves to the restroom. We got some mail from Emily Y who really appreciated the callback from Phyllis's wedding about Phyllis being a good bowler. Oh yeah. I also enjoyed that. If you guys remember, Bob has a speech at their reception where he refers to Phyllis as quote a hell of a bowler. That's right. I think we should take a break before we go to Michael's Lonely Hearts Party. I do too. Is that okay? I think we should too. Before we go to break,
还有另一个场景，你们谈到你们去了戴夫·马修斯乐队的演唱会。是的。我记得拍摄时，他们有很好的座位，菲利斯还去了后台诸如此类的事情。是的。我们当时想，哦，天哪，鲍勃和菲利斯真是太酷了。然后他们借口去洗手间。我们收到了来自艾米Y的信，她非常欣赏菲利斯婚礼上的那个梗，即菲利斯是个保龄球高手。哦，是的。我也很欣赏这一点。如果你们还记得的话，鲍勃在他们的婚宴上有过一次发言，他称菲利斯为“绝对是个保龄球高手”。没错。我想在去迈克尔的孤单的心派对之前，我们应该先休息一下。我也这么觉得。这样可以吗？我觉得我们也应该去。在休息之前，
I just want to say one thing. What is it? That I love that Bob says, I don't know how you work with that one jackass and then that new jackass and that other jackass. Yeah. And Phyllis is like, he means Michael Dwight and Andy and Jim's like, oh, I knew who he was talking about. I knew. All right. Let's go to break. We are back. And since I shared about my hot feet today, I thought I would also share about another wardrobe malfunction that I discovered during my bathroom break, which is that I put my underwear on inside out today. Oh, I'm having that day, everybody. I think I look really put together today. Do I? Or is it? No. You didn't say yes. In fact,
我只想说一件事。是什么？我喜欢鲍勃说的那句，“我不知道你怎么能和那个混蛋，还有那个新混蛋，以及另一个混蛋一起工作。”是的。然后菲利斯说，他指的是迈克尔、德怀特和安迪，吉姆说，哦，我知道他说的是谁。我知道。好吧。我们去休息吧。我们回来了。既然我分享了我今天脚很热的事，我想我也该分享一下我在上洗手间时发现的另一个服装故障，那就是我今天把内裤穿反了。哦，我今天正经历这样的一天，各位。我觉得我今天打扮得很得体。是吗？还是说？没有。你没说“是”。事实上，
you got to look on your face like, how do I say this? You know what? You know why? I don't want you to move. Don't move. Don't move. I just want to take a picture of your hair and then I'm going to answer. Okay. Now you just said, I feel pretty, pretty put together today. Now I want you to look at this. Okay. Okay. Now your outfit, lady, it's all happening. You have your little shirt and pants and your fancy sneakers. I like your look today. Good. Okay. Okay. All right. Let's go to the Lonely Hearts Party. Let's do because Michael wants to go around and have everyone tell their worst relationship story. Michael has this way of like, oh, you don't feel good. I want you to feel worse. Yeah. I think he thinks this is going to be, I don't know, bonding cathartic. Well,
你脸上露出了那种表情，好像在想，我该怎么说呢？你知道吗？你知道为什么吗？我不想让你动。别动。别动。我只是想给你的头发拍张照片，然后我再回答。好吧。现在你刚才说，我觉得我今天打扮得挺得体的。现在我想让你看看这个。好的。好的。现在你的行头，女士，全齐了。你有你的小衬衫和裤子，还有你那双时髦的运动鞋。我喜欢你今天的造型。很好。好的。好的。我们去“孤单的心”派对吧。我们去吧，因为迈克尔想四处走走，让每个人都讲讲他们最糟糕的情感故事。迈克尔有一种方式，就像是，哦，你感觉不好吗？我要让你感觉更糟。是的。我想他以为这会是，我不知道，促进感情，宣泄情绪。好吧，
you guys, we had to sit in a circle facing each other. We could not get through these scenes. We each went around and said the most ridiculous things. There was way more than what you're seeing here. There was more on the page and we just were laughing all day. Also for the supporting cast, we got to have Steve all to ourselves and interact with him and as Michael Scott and our characters and it just was a fricking hilariously fun afternoon. I love how Oscar doesn't want to share and then he clearly has been going on and on. Yeah. It actually in the script starts with Meredith and she talks about the woman her husband left her for. I think we need to hear some of it. So my husband ran off with some broad. He was she. She was our garbage woman. Nice. I totally
你们大家，我们不得不围成一圈面对面坐着。我们简直无法演完这些场景。我们每个人轮流说出最荒谬的话。这比你们在这里看到的要多得多。剧本上还有更多内容，我们一整天都在笑。而且对于配角演员来说，我们能独自拥有史蒂夫，与他互动，作为迈克尔·斯科特和我们的角色互动，这简直是一个该死的爆笑而有趣的下午。我喜欢奥斯卡不想分享，然后他显然说个没完没了。是的。剧本里其实是从梅雷迪思开始的，她谈到了她丈夫抛弃她所找的那个女人。我觉得我们需要听听其中的一部分。所以我的丈夫跟某个荡妇私奔了。他是个。她。她是我们的垃圾女工。不错。我完全
get it. I mean, she was strong. She had a career. She could heave a bag of garbage as high as a two-story house. So sorry, Meredith. My kids call her mom now. I guess it's for the best. Oh my god. Okay. All right. Well, let's let's who else? Kids. She said my kids. I know. I know. More evidence that there's more than one. More evidence and then I don't know if you heard at the end. Steve was Michael goes, oh god. Okay. Like every time he did that after everyone's story, it was so hard to keep it together. Michael tries to get Kelly to share but she insists that I guess her heart wasn't broken, that Ryan's okay, that his heart was in the right place. Michael reminds her that his heart and body are now in Thailand having random sex. Awesome. Again, great pep talk, Michael.
理解。我的意思是，她很强壮。她有事业。她能把一袋垃圾举得跟两层楼一样高。真遗憾，梅雷迪思。我的孩子们现在叫她妈妈。我想这也是最好的结果。哦，天哪。好吧。好吧，那让我们，还有谁？孩子们。她说我的孩子们。我知道。我知道。有更多的证据表明不止一个。更多的证据，然后我不知道你们最后有没有听到。史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔说，哦，天哪。好吧。就像他在每个人的故事讲完后都这么说一样，太难忍住不笑了。迈克尔试图让凯莉分享，但她坚信我猜她的心没有碎，瑞恩很好，他的心在正确的地方。迈克尔提醒她，他的心和身体现在正在泰国乱搞。太棒了。
Angela had a talking head here. It's in the deleted scenes. I want to play it, Jenna, because I then want to read you what was my alt talking head because we talk a lot about how our alternate talking heads sometimes would just be all over the map. And I want you to hear the difference. Okay. Play what would have actually ended up in the episode if we'd had more time. I do not have a Valentine this year. I have recently got out of two long-term relationships. So I want to wait before I do that again. Okay. So that's what we shot. Okay. Amazing. Amazing. Here was my alt, one of my alts guys. The major holidays are Christmas, Easter and the fourth of July. Valentine's Day is bull. And then they said we could try it this way. Valentine's Day
再次说明，精彩的动员演讲，迈克尔。安吉拉在这里有一个独白。它在被删减的片段里。我想放给你们听，珍娜，因为我接着想读给你听我的备选独白是什么，因为我们经常谈论我们的备选独白有时会多么天马行空。我想让你听听区别。好吧。如果我们有更多时间，实际上会出现在剧集里的内容是这样的。我今年没有情人节。我最近结束了两段长期的恋爱关系。所以我现在想等等再开始下一段。好的。所以这就是我们拍摄的内容。好的。太惊人了。太惊人了。这就是我的备选，我的备选之一，伙计们。主要的节日是圣诞节、复活节和独立日。情人节简直是胡扯。然后他们说我们可以这样试一次。情人节
is bullpucky. But that was my alt. Well, Angela does share her, I guess, heartbreak story, which is that there was a time when she was in a relationship with two men, both of whom she loved and they ended up dueling over her. And Oscar is like, we know we were there, Dwight and Andy. And she's like, no, this was years ago when I was living in Ohio, John Mark and John David. Ohio. I know. John Mark and John David. What was her other life? And then Oscar's like, wait a second. You had two sets of different men actually duel over you. And I had so much fun saying, I guess I have. Huh. And then your deleted talking head implies that you might do this a third time, but you need a moment. I need a moment before you do that again.
简直是胡扯。但那是我的备选。好吧，安吉拉确实分享了她的，我猜是心碎的故事，那就是曾有一段时间她同时和两个男人交往，她深爱着他们俩，结果他们为了她决斗了。奥斯卡就说，我们知道，我们在场，德怀特和安迪。她说，不，那是多年前我住在俄亥俄州的时候，约翰·马克和约翰·大卫。俄亥俄州。我知道。约翰·马克和约翰·大卫。她过的是什么人生啊？然后奥斯卡说，等一下。你竟然有两套不同的男人为了你而真正决斗过。我当时说这句话时觉得太有趣了，我猜我有。哼。然后你被删减的独白暗示你可能会有第三次，但你需要一点时间。我在这样做之前需要一点时间。
Again. And then you guys, Oscar's whole story was so great. There was so much more to it. I wish it hadn't been cut. He talks about like the whole entire way he met this guy and how it all played out. And it really builds and we're hanging on his every word. And a lot of that had to be cut for time, but it was really fun to shoot. We also find out where Andy is because, guys, he has not been in this episode at all. Where is he? He is on his honeymoons. Yeah. Oscar said, you know, he had to put full deposits down that he couldn't get back, non-refundables on these honeymoon. So he's just going and doing them all. He's got a hot air balloon thing of massage. Lady, this got me thinking. How many times does this happen? Do people share
再次。然后你们大家，奥斯卡的故事太棒了。里面还有更多内容。我真希望它没有被删减。他讲述了他是如何遇到这个家伙的整个过程以及一切是如何展开的，这真的很引人入胜，我们对他的每一句话都铭记在心。其中很多为了赶时间不得不被剪掉，但拍摄起来真的非常有趣。我们还发现安迪在哪里，因为，伙计们，他这一集根本没出现。他在哪里？他在度蜜月。是的。奥斯卡说，你知道的，他付了全额押金且无法退还，这些蜜月旅行费用是不可退款的。所以他只能去把它们都度完。他有一个热气球项目和一个按摩。女士，这让我陷入了沉思。这种情况发生过多少次？人们会分享
about this where they had an engagement that got broken off and they've already paid for the honeymoon and who goes on it? I guess it happens quite a bit. I know someone it happened to. You do. What was the honeymoon destination? I think the honeymoon destination was Hawaii. And what they did was they each like canceled their plane ticket and they got the credit and my friend came and visited me on what would have been her honeymoon week. So instead of flying to Hawaii, she rerouted it to LA and then I took her to Laguna Beach and we just hung out the week that it would have been her honeymoon. Oh my gosh, you have such a personal story about this. Well, in my search online about these stories, guess what I found? What? In March of 2019, The New York Times ran an article saying
关于他们的订婚告吹了，他们已经付了蜜月钱，然后谁去度蜜月的事情吗？我想这还挺常见的。我认识一个经历过这种事的人。你认识。蜜月目的地是哪里？我想蜜月目的地是夏威夷。他们所做的是，他们各自退了机票，拿到了退款信用额度，然后我的朋友在我本该是她蜜月的那周来看望我。所以她没有飞往夏威夷，而是改道去了洛杉矶，然后我带她去了拉古纳海滩，我们就在她本该是蜜月的那个星期一起闲逛。哦，天哪，你竟然有这样一个私人故事。好吧，在我网上搜索这些故事的过程中，你猜我发现了什么？什么？在2019年3月，纽约时报发表了一篇文章说
that traveling alone for your honeymoon is actually on trend. What? Yeah, I know. I'm sorry, wait, but the marriage happened. The marriage happened. And then you go by yourself on a honeymoon trip? Both go separately by yourself. They said it's been given two nicknames. Solo moons are uni moons. And according to Jessica Carbino, who's an online dating expert and a sociologist for the dating app Bumble, she says, frankly, the idea of separate honeymoon may signal the continued evolution of marriage. Given the recognition that for most couples today, marriage and partnership is considered all consuming with the partner needing to fulfill every role, physical, spiritual, emotional, and sexual, perhaps separate vacations is a recognition among some couples that all expectations cannot
独自去度蜜月实际上是一种趋势。什么？是的，我知道。对不起，等等，但是婚姻已经发生了。婚姻已经发生了。然后你自己一个人去度蜜月旅行？两人分别独自前往。他们说这有两个昵称。“独行月”或“单人月”。根据约会应用Bumble的在线约会专家兼社会学家杰西卡·卡尔比诺的说法，她表示，坦率地说，分开度蜜月的想法可能标志着婚姻的不断演变。考虑到大多数现代夫妇都认识到，婚姻和伴侣关系被认为是全方位的，伴侣需要满足每一个角色——生理、精神、情感和性。也许分开度假是一些夫妇的一种认识，即单一的个人无法满足所有的期望。这在推特上引起了轰动。看看我的脸。我知道整篇文章。
be met by a single person. This caused a stir on Twitter. We'll look at my face. I know this whole article. So Helen Fisher from the Kinsey Institute, guys. I'm not related, but you know, same last name. Helen Fisher, who works at the Kinsey Institute said, perhaps I'm old fashioned, but I think it should be marked. You are at a new stage in your life when you marry and you are missing out on triggering the three most valuable brain systems for a lasting relationship. I'm with this. Same. Like, oh my gosh, you just got married. This is a celebration of your union. Isn't the whole idea to go take a trip together? Yeah, I just think it's a milestone that is best celebrated together. I mean, I do see the value in once you are married. And especially if you
所以金赛研究所的海伦·菲舍尔，伙计们。我们没有亲戚关系，但你知道的，姓氏一样。在金赛研究所工作的海伦·菲舍尔说，也许我很老派，但我觉得应该举行庆祝。当你结婚时，你正处于人生一个新的阶段，而你错失了触发持久关系的三个最宝贵的大脑系统的机会。我同意这个观点。一样。就像，哦，天哪，你们刚刚结婚。这是对你们结合的庆祝。难道整个主意不就是一起去旅行吗？是的，我只觉得这是一个最好一起庆祝的里程碑。我的意思是，我确实看到了结婚后的价值。特别是如果你
have kids, there is a great restorative, wonderful indulgence if you can take a trip solo. Right? I mean, my dream vacation is me going and sleeping somewhere for three days, you know. So yes, sign me up. But when you first get married, you've also been married a long time and you have young children and the idea of getting to sleep in. That's what I'm saying. No, I've been married over 11 years. And yes, I'm thinking what solo vacation? I mean, even now, if there's a chance that we could have someone watch our kids, I'd want to go somewhere with Lee for three days. We could just sleep. I think he'd like it too. I get excited when Josh and I can both run errands at the same time together. Yes. If I turn to him. That's sometimes a date night for it. It is. Like,
有孩子，如果你能独自旅行一次，那将是一种极好的、恢复精力的、美妙的放纵。对吧？我的梦想假期就是我去某处睡上三天，你知道的。所以，是的，算我一个。但当你刚结婚时，你也已经结婚很久了，而且你有年幼的孩子，能够睡个懒觉的想法。这就是我所说的。不，我已经结婚11年多了。是的，我在想什么单人假期？即使现在，如果有机会让别人帮我们看孩子，我也想和李一起去某个地方待三天。我们可以好好睡一觉。我想他也会喜欢。每当乔什和我能同时一起去办杂事时，我就会感到兴奋。是的。如果我转过身对他说。那有时就是我们的约会之夜。确实如此。就像，
if I turn to him and say, I got to go to Target and he's like, Oh, I can go too. I'm like, Oh, no way. I'm so excited. I hear all of that. Here's the thing. I'll just say it. I like to be around my husband all the time. We don't even have to be talking to each other. I like to text him all day. I like to get his texts. I mean, I don't know. I like him. I know you want to go on honeymoon with him. I know. I want to go to honeymoon with my person. Anyway, so Andy is on sort of a sad uni moon. Well, I'll tell you where he really was. Oh, where Ed Helms was. Yes. Ed was filming the hangover in Las Vegas. Oh, that's right. This is when we had the crazy schedule for him. He was so tired, Jenna. He remember he would get off the plane from Vegas and come straight to our set.
如果我转过身对他说，我得去塔吉特百货，而他说，哦，我也能去。我就想，哦，不会吧。我太兴奋了。我听懂了所有这些。事情是这样的。我只想说。我喜欢一直和我丈夫在一起。我们甚至不需要说话。我喜欢整天给他发短信。我喜欢收到他的短信。我的意思是，我不知道。我喜欢他。我知道你想跟他一起去度蜜月。我知道。我想和我的人一起去度蜜月。不管怎样，安迪正在进行一场有点悲伤的“单人月”。好吧，我来告诉你他真正去了哪里。哦，爱德华·赫尔姆斯去哪了？是的。艾德当时正在拉斯维加斯拍摄《宿醉》。哦，对了。这是我们为他制定疯狂日程的时候。他太累了，珍娜。他，你记得他会坐从拉斯维加斯的飞机下来，直接来到我们的片场。
Yeah. Here's what we did. It was this big negotiation between the studios. He would be on set with us Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday. We only got him three days. Right. Then he would fly after work and start work on the hangover Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Monday. He was working seven days, but there were two weeks when he had to work on the hangover all week. And this was one of those weeks. Remember, BJ was also gone right now filming In Glorious Bastards. So two of our fellows were off making movies. So they created these storylines for these guys so that they could do their movies. They got very creative with this idea of Andy being on his honeymoon because after this episode aired, NBC uploaded photos of Ed pretending to be on vacation.
是的。我们是这样做的。这是各大制片厂之间的一场巨大谈判。他周二、周三、周四会在片场陪我们。我们只有他三天时间。对。然后他会在下班后飞走，并在周五、周六、周日、周一来开始拍摄《宿醉》。他一周工作七天，但有两周他必须整周都在拍《宿醉》。这就是其中一周。记住，BJ当时也不在，正在拍摄《无耻混蛋》。所以我们有两个家伙出去拍电影了。因此，他们为这些家伙创造了这些故事情节，以便他们能够去拍电影。他们对安迪在度蜜月这个想法上非常有创意，因为在这集播出后，NBC上传了艾德假装在度假的照片。
They put him in the Angela Martin, Andy Bernard wedding website. They had him pose and all these different outfits in front of a green screen. They had him scuba diving standing in front of a hot air balloon in Napa Valley and visiting Epcot Center. I think I might still have those. I found the one of him in front of the balloon. Yeah. And I also found the message that they wrote from Andy to everyone on the wedding website. It said this, quote, wanted all my bros and bras and cyberspace to know that the old nard dog is doing just fine. Back to our group of sadness. Kevin is going to share about his breakup from Stacy. Yeah. Michael decides to become a problem solver. He says there's got to be a way to get all the
他们把他放进了安吉拉·马丁和安迪·伯纳德的婚礼网站里。他们让他站在绿幕前摆出各种不同的服装造型。他们让他穿着潜水服，站在纳帕谷的热气球前，还参观了艾普科特中心。我想我可能还留着那些照片。我找到了他站在气球前的那个。是的。我还找到了他们在婚礼网站上写给所有人的安迪的留言。上面写着，引用一下，“想让网络空间里的所有兄弟姐妹们知道，老纳德狗一切都好。”回到我们的悲伤小组。凯文要分享他与斯黛西的分手经历。是的。迈克尔决定成为一个问题解决者。他说一定有一种方法能把所有的
lonely people together. A mixer. First white says a giant net. Jenna, I thought that that was an improv and I went and looked in the script and it was completely 100% written. It's so funny. It's so funny. But no, you're right. Michael is saying a mixer, aka an old fashioned meat market. They're going to put up flyers. Yep. They're going to invite people and on the flyer. Michael is going to make sure that he is sending out a beacon to this lost glove lady. Yeah. And he says, you know what? Cupid is going to shoot his sparrow at unsuspecting victims. Yeah. His sparrow. A funny little bird, but he gets the job done. That's right. That tickled me because I feel like I get phrases one or two words off.
孤独的人聚在一起。联谊会。首先，德怀特说的是一张巨网。珍娜，我以为那是即兴发挥，我去查了剧本，发现它是完全100%写进剧本里的。太搞笑。太搞笑。但，不，你说得对。迈克尔说的是联谊会，也就是老式的肉类市场。他们要贴出传单。是的。他们要邀请人们，在传单上。迈克尔要确保他向这位丢失手套的女士发出信号。是的。他说，你知道的，丘比特要向毫无防备的受害者发射他的麻雀。是的。他的麻雀。一只搞笑的小鸟，但他把事情办妥了。没错。这让我觉得很好笑，因为我觉得我的成语总是差了一两个字。
You feel like it? You do. You do. Why is there a plotting? Oh my gosh. Because we thought the same thing when you said it. Like there's a debate to it. I feel like it might be possible that in this moment, I really relate to Michael. When the mixer gets underway, two women enter. Yes, Lynn and Rhee. Rhee was played by Tate Hancock. She's done a ton of comedy television work, everything from scrubs, community, super store. She has been on Monk and I can't believe I'm going to say this. What? I was so excited. What? John Wick. No. I've seen John Wick. What? With Keanu Reeves? No. How does she know him? What? No. Oh my gosh. You are so on Keanu today. No. She was in a television pilot called Hummingbird. Oh my Lord. I should just know today
你觉得是吗？确实是。确实是。为什么会有掌声？哦，天哪。因为你这么说的时候，我们也这么想。就像有一场辩论。我觉得有可能在这一刻，我真的和迈克尔共情了。当联谊会开始时，两个女人进来了。是的，琳和瑞。瑞由塔特·汉考克饰演。她做过大量的喜剧电视工作，从《实习医生风云》、《废柴联盟》到《超级超市》。她演过《神探阿蒙》，而且我不敢相信我要说这个。什么？我太兴奋了。什么？《疾速追杀》。不。我看过《疾速追杀》。什么？和基努·里维斯一起？不。她怎么认识他？什么？不。哦，天哪。你今天对基努太着迷了。不。她曾出演过一部名为《蜂鸟》的试播集。哦，天哪。我今天早该知道
all of your anecdotes are Hummingbird related. I mean, I couldn't believe it. When I was looking her up, she played Sienna. The series was a thriller about a young girl who vanishes. The other lady who has entered is Lynn. She was played by Lisa K Wyatt. This is her first of four episodes. Yes. She's going to become a love interest for Kevin. In addition to her numerous film television commercial credits, such as Donnie Darko, Legally Blonde and Days of Our Lives, Lisa Wyatt also does stand up and along with her husband, she coaches other actors in an acting technique, acting technique called the mechanics of believability at the acting garage in Los Angeles. I thought she was very believable. There you go. Spot on. Did you guys all notice that
你所有的趣闻轶事都跟《蜂鸟》有关。我的意思是，我简直不敢相信。当我查她的时候，她饰演西恩娜。这部剧是一部关于一个年轻女孩失踪的惊悚片。进来的另一位女士是琳。她由丽莎·K·怀特饰演。这是她四集中的第一集。是的。她将成为凯文的恋爱对象。除了她众多电影、电视剧和商业广告作品（如《死亡幻觉》、《律政俏佳人》和《我们的日子》）之外，丽莎·怀特还表演单口喜剧，并且和她的丈夫一起，在洛杉矶的演艺车库指导其他演员一种名为“可信度机制”的表演技巧。我觉得她演得非常可信。就是这样。太准了。你们大家都注意到
Reeve is dressed like Angela Martin? Yes. We got mail about it. People wanted to know if that was on purpose. I think so. Yes. I think so. Yes. Well, Michael's going to bring Lynn right on over to Kevin. He wants to make a love connection. I mean, Michael's playing Cupid. He is. Kevin tries to chatter up, but he kind of keeps putting his foot in his mouth. He does mention the circle drive-in. That's a real place. I looked it up. It's in Scranton and it's still in operation. One of my favorites, though, is when Michael tries to set up Meredith. Mm-hmm. He says, so, Eric, you mentioned that you were in tool and die repair. I loved that. Yeah. Do you think he works at Crest, tool and die?
瑞的穿着打扮像安吉拉·马丁吗？是的。我们收到了相关的信件。人们想知道那是不是故意的。我想是的。是的。我想是的。好吧，迈克尔要把琳直接带到凯文身边。他想促成一段美好的姻缘。我的意思是，迈克尔在扮演丘比特。他是的。凯文试图跟她聊天，但他有点总是祸从口出。他确实提到了环形免下车影院。那是真的。我查过了。它在斯克兰顿，现在仍在营业。不过我最喜欢的一幕是，迈克尔试图给梅雷迪思做媒。嗯哼。他说，所以，埃里克，你提到你是做刀具和模具修理的。我太喜欢这个了。是的。你觉得他在克雷斯特刀具模具厂工作吗？
Probably. It's on the sign, down in the lobby. Yes. This is like a business park, right? Yes, exactly. Eric says, I am. And then Michael says, well, Meredith recently had a total hysterectomy, so that's sort of a repair. All right. I'll let you two talk. Would you like a guest star breakdown on Eric? I would. He was played by Jason Rogel, and I found a very interesting crossover connection. I know it. Tell us, Angela. Jason and I, when he played Eric, we didn't know each other, but years later, we would both be in the Netflix movie, Toe Girl, together. Yes. Mm-hmm. So crazy. I know. A little mini-office reunion. He played the doctor, the pediatrician, when Steve's on, who plays my husband and I, we go to meet with the pediatrician because our daughter is so incredibly
很可能。大厅下面的招牌上有写。是的。这是一个商业园，对吧？是的，没错。埃里克说，我是。然后迈克尔说，哦，梅雷迪思最近刚做了全子宫切除术，所以这也算是一种修理。好吧。你们俩聊吧。你想听听关于埃里克的客串演员分析吗？我想听。他由杰森·罗格尔饰演，我发现了一个非常有趣的交叉联系。我知道。告诉我们吧，安吉拉。杰森和我，他演埃里克时，我们并不认识，但多年后我们一起出演了网飞电影《寻爱之旅》。是的。嗯哼。太疯狂了。我知道。一个小型的办公室重聚。他扮演医生，那个儿科医生，当史蒂夫在的时候，他扮演我丈夫，我们去找儿科医生，因为我们的女儿在这么小的年纪就
tall at such a young age, and he played the pediatrician. Should we go to the restaurant? We should, because Bob and Phyllis have not come back from the bathroom. No. And Jim and Pam are very hungry. Their food is there. This is getting so awkward. They're discussing, when are you allowed to eat? And Jim says, did you get hot food? And Pam says, no. She got cold food, and he said, then I think you need to wait. Right. You have to wait for the other people. And Pam says, Bob got hot food, and I think his fries are getting cold, and then they start eating his fries, and then they eat his steak. I know. Did you see how I was really eating the steak? Lady, I was starving. I was like so excited to eat the fries and the
长得如此不可思议地高，他扮演的就是那个儿科医生。我们应该去餐馆吗？我们应该去，因为鲍勃和菲利斯还没从洗手间回来。没有。而且吉姆和帕姆饿坏了。他们的食物就摆在那里。这变得太尴尬了。他们在讨论，什么时候才可以开吃？吉姆说，你点的热食吗？帕姆说，没有。她点的是凉食，他说，那我觉得你需要等等。没错。你得等其他人。帕姆说，鲍勃点的是热食，我觉得他的薯条都快凉了，然后他们开始吃他的薯条，然后他们吃他的牛排。我知道。你看到我是怎么真正地在大口吃牛排吗？女士，我饿坏了。我简直迫不及待地想吃薯条和
steak. That was real. That's my real hunger. I thought it rang pretty true, just knowing you the way I know you when you get hungry. Yeah. That you would not hesitate to take food off someone else's plate. Especially because they hadn't been on that plate yet. When I was a caterer. Would you take things and nibble? You know, when I was clearing the tables, if there was like a roll or like part of a chicken breast that had clearly not been touched, I would eat it. I mean, I was hungry and I, you know, was a struggling actor. It was a free meal. I would sort of piece it together from everybody's plate. Let me tell you something, Angela, because you brought up food and eating for me. You know, it's important to me. And it's so important
牛排。那是真的。那是我真实的饥饿感。我觉得这很真实，以我对你的了解，当你饿的时候。是的。你绝不会犹豫去拿别人盘子里的食物。尤其是因为那些食物还没碰过那个盘子。当我做餐饮服务员的时候。你会拿东西吃吗？你知道的，当我清理盘子时，如果有面包卷或者鸡胸肉的一部分明显没有被碰过，我就会吃。我的意思是，我很饿，而且，你知道的，我是一个苦苦挣扎的演员。这是一顿免费的饭。我会把每个人的盘子拼凑起来吃。让我告诉你一件事，安吉拉，因为你提到了食物和吃东西。你知道的，这对我来说很重要。这对我来说太重要了
to me, this idea of like being at a large dinner party, and people are getting served food. And when do you get to eat your food? That I actually looked it up once. Like the etiquette of it? Yes. And I read that in a large dinner party, if they're serving something cold, you have to wait for everybody to get their cold dish, like a salad or a cold soup, before you start eating. But if something hot is being served, after two or more people have been served that hot dish, you can begin eating while you wait for the rest of the party to get their dish. And I've stuck with that in my life when I've been at like, let's say a table of 10. If I get my hot dish, I'm the fourth person to get it. I start eating it because that's
，比如在一个大型晚宴上，人们正在被上菜。你什么时候可以吃你的食物？我曾经专门查过一次。就像礼仪方面？是的。我读到过在一个大型晚宴上，如果他们端上来的是凉菜，你必须等每个人都拿到他们的凉菜，比如沙拉或冷汤，然后才能开始吃。但如果端上来的是热菜，在两名或更多的客人被端上热菜后，你就可以开始吃，同时等待聚会的其余人拿到他们的菜。当我在比如一张10人桌旁时，我在我的生活中一直坚持这一点。如果我拿到了我的热菜，我是第四个拿到的。我开始吃，因为书上就是这么写的，而且因为我想吃。既然我们聊到了餐饮礼仪，我再稍微深入一点。这里有一些其他的餐饮礼仪规则给你。显然，如果你拿到了一个餐桌小面包，礼仪规定你应该一次只给一口抹黄油。你不应该把整块面包都抹上。走开。
what the book said and because I want to. But I digged a little deeper since we're on the topic of dining etiquette. Here are some other dining etiquette rules for you. Apparently, if you get a dinner roll, etiquette says you should only butter one bite at a time. You shouldn't butter your whole piece of bread. Get out. Isn't that crazy? I'm going to put butter all over it. I butter the whole thing. I want more butter. But if you butter it one bite at a time, you might get it. You're double dipping. But no, because you're using a special knife. And you're putting it on your bread and you're taking a bite and then you're doing that knife on that shared communal butter again. Etiquette. I don't think you're right. Well, that's what
是不是很疯狂？我要在上面抹满黄油。我把整块都抹了。我想要更多黄油。但如果你一次只给一口抹黄油，你可能会拿到。你在二次蘸取。但不对，因为你用的是一把特殊的刀。你把它抹在面包上，然后咬一口，然后你又在那个共享的公共黄油上用那把刀。礼仪。我觉得你不对。好吧，书上就是这么
it said. Okay. Also, out of respect for the chef, you should always try several bites of your food before adding any salt or pepper. Well, we always say that to our kids. Like, try it before you salt it, guys. If someone asks you to pass the salt, do you know you're supposed to pass the salt and pepper together? I do. They're a pair. They like to travel together. They travel together. If you're enjoying a family style meal, you're supposed to pass the dishes clockwise around the table. Oh gosh, at our family, it's like a free for all. Same. Also, this one I found very interesting. If you leave the table and you're in the middle of a meal, do you know where you're supposed to put your napkin? To the left of your plate. That's what I thought, to the side
写的。好的。此外，出于对厨师的尊重，在添加任何盐或胡椒之前，你应该总是先品尝几口你的食物。好吧，我们总是对我们的孩子这样说。就像，在加盐之前先尝尝，伙计们。如果有人请求你递盐，你知道你应该把盐和胡椒一起递过去吗？我知道。它们是一对。它们喜欢一起旅行。它们一起旅行。如果你在享受家庭风格的聚餐，你应该按顺时针方向在桌子周围传递盘子。哦天哪，在我们的家庭里，就像是一场各自为战的混战。一样。还有，我觉得这个非常有趣。如果你离开座位，而你正吃到一半，你知道你的餐巾纸应该放在哪里吗？放在你盘子的左边。我也是这么想的，放在你盘子的
of your plate. Yeah. Your chair. What? I'm supposed to set it on your chair. Gross. My butt was just there. Why do I want to put that up? What? No. Maybe your hot feet were tucked up under your butt. I know. I could have a hot foot inside out underwear chair. Yeah. That's gross. Why are we talking about my chair? You brought up all of these things. The hot feet, your underwear, the chair, this is all your stuff. Why are you making me talk about this? Pam and Jim can't take it anymore. It's been so long. They're like, did they ditch us? Yeah. Where are they? Maybe they just left. Well, they go to look for them over by the restrooms. Yeah. And what do they hear moaning behind the door? It is on. They are clearly getting it on. Jim and Pam are horrified. But then, when they come back to the
旁边。是的。你的椅子。什么？我应该把它放在你的椅子上。太恶心了。我的屁股刚刚才坐在那上面。为什么我要把它放上去？什么？不对。也许你的热脚塞在你的屁股底下了。我知道。我可能有一张带有热脚和穿反内裤的椅子。是的。这太恶心了。我们为什么要讨论我的椅子？是你提出了所有这些事情。热脚、你的内裤、椅子，这全都是你的东西。你为什么逼我谈论这个？帕姆和吉姆再也受不了了。已经过去这么久了。他们想，他们把我们甩了吗？是的。他们在哪里？也许他们只是走了。好吧，他们去洗手间附近找他们。是的。然后他们在门后听到了什么呻吟声？开始了。他们显然在亲热。吉姆和帕姆吓坏了。但是然后，当他们回到
table, can we talk about Phyllis? She's so flustered. She's like sweaty, chugging her water. Phyllis should get an emmy for that moment. She's so brilliant. It's so good. And then, at 17 minutes, 35 seconds, can we please talk about the way that Bob Vance holds his fork when he starts cutting his steak? He's like got his fork in like a fist and he stabbed it into the steak and he's cutting it. He feeds it to Phyllis. I had a question about this moment. Okay. He says, do you want any steak? And she's like, sure. And he passes it over to her and she says, no mushrooms. He says, sorry, I forgot. And then she eats the steak. I was like, this is so nuanced. This feels so personal and intimate. Was this written? And I went to the script and this is not in the script.
桌边时，我们能谈谈菲利斯吗？她慌乱极了。她满头大汗，狂灌着水。菲利斯应该凭那个时刻获得艾美奖。她太才华横溢了。太棒了。然后，在17分35秒的时候，我们能谈谈鲍勃·范斯开始切牛排时拿叉子的姿势吗？他像握着拳头一样握着叉子，把它捅进牛排里，然后开始切。他喂给菲利斯吃。我对这个时刻有个疑问。好的。他说，你想吃牛排吗？她说，好啊。然后他把它递给她，她说，不要蘑菇。他说，对不起，我忘了。然后她吃下了牛排。我当时想，这太细腻了。这感觉太个人化、太亲密了。这是剧本写的吗？我查了剧本，这根本不在剧本里。
The whole steak thing, is it? Him feeding her in the mushroom. Wow. That's crazy because I just remember shooting it several times. So it must have been an on the day thing because it wasn't a one-time improv because they had to set up that camera specifically to get that look from me and John. And I remember that we had a hard time holding it because it was very funny. But my question is, was the mushroom thing an accident? I don't remember. When he stabs the steak and maybe in real life Phyllis doesn't like mushrooms. Maybe not. So she just improved no mushrooms. I don't know. It's so specific. It's so good. I loved it. Back at the mixer, Michael keeps looking at the door. He's really hoping Glove Girl will show up. And Dwight is like, why do you keep looking
整段牛排的桥段，是吗？他喂她吃蘑菇。哇。这太疯狂了，因为我只记得拍了好几次。所以这一定是一个现场即兴发挥的事情，因为它不是一次性的即兴创作，因为他们必须专门架设那个摄像机来捕捉我和约翰的那个表情。我记得我们很难忍住不笑，因为太搞笑了。但我的问题是，关于蘑菇的事是个意外吗？我不记得了。当他捅牛排时，也许现实生活中菲利斯不喜欢蘑菇。也许吧。所以她只是即兴说了一句“不要蘑菇”。我不知道。太具体了。太棒了。回到联谊会现场，迈克尔一直盯着门看。他真的很希望“手套女孩”能出现。而德怀特却说，你为什么一直盯着前门看？有人在跟踪你吗？等一下。我们收到了艾米P提出的一个关于此事的粉丝问题。她说，当德怀特问迈克尔是否有人在跟踪他时，奥斯卡说，你为什么总是往那方面想？这个办公室里曾经有人跟踪过任何人吗？艾米说，是的，奥斯卡。罗伊。是的。还记得罗伊吗？他绝对是在跟踪吉姆，而德怀特拯救了世界。听着，德怀特随时准备好武器。有一个时刻，一个不是迈克尔心上人的女人出现了，他把她拒之门外。
at the front door? Is someone after you? Okay, wait. We got a fan question about that from Amy P. She says, when Dwight asks Michael if someone's after him and Oscar says, why do you always go to that? Has anyone ever been after anyone in this office? Amy says, yes, Oscar. Roy. Yes. Remember Roy? He was definitely after Jim and Dwight saved the day. Listen, Dwight is ready with weaponry all the time. There is a moment where a woman shows up who is not Michael's lady and he turns her away. Everyone groans. I don't know that he turns her away, but she walks in and everyone is so excited for Glove Girl that when Michael is like, nope, they're like, ugh. And she leaves. Yeah. This unnamed woman. I looked her up. Do you know who she is? Oh,
所有人都在叹气。我不知道他是不是把她拒之门外，但她走了进来，每个人都对“手套女孩”兴奋不已，当迈克尔说“不”时，他们就“呃”。然后她就走了。是的。这个未透露姓名的女人。我查过她。你知道她是谁吗？哦，
I do. Dorian Frankel. Uh-huh. She was Allison Jones Casting Associate for the office after Phyllis left. Let me tell you a little bit about Dorian. I met her a lifetime ago. Dorian, if you're hearing this, hi, it was so fun to see your face. We did improv together at Improv Olympic, also known as iOS. We were on a long form team called, ready for this, Fluffers. Oh, Dorian, do you remember this? If you hear this, we were on a team called Fluffers. We would rehearse in her apartment and she was lovely and I'm so happy for her. She recently won an Emmy for Casting Veep. Yes. So she's amazing. Dorian, oh my gosh, flashed from the past. So that was my other crossover connection with a guest star in this episode. Amazing. Dwight has kind of zeroed in on Ri,
我知道。多莉安·弗兰克尔。嗯哼。在菲利斯离开后，她是《办公室》的艾利森·琼斯选角助理。让我跟你聊聊多莉安。我一辈子前就认识她了。多莉安，如果你听到这段，嗨，见到你的面孔太开心了。我们在“即兴奥林匹克”（也称为iO）一起做过即兴表演。我们曾在一个长篇即兴喜剧团队里，准备好听这个了吗？叫“绒毛球”。哦，多莉安，你还记得吗？如果你听到这个，我们曾在一个叫“绒毛球”的团队里。我们会在她的公寓里排练，她很可爱，我为她感到非常高兴。她最近凭借为《副总统》选角赢得了艾美奖。是的。所以她太棒了。多莉安，哦，天哪，真是往事重现。所以这就是我和这一集客串演员的另一个交叉联系。太惊人了。德怀特有点把目标锁定在瑞身上了，
woman who is dressed like Angela, but not for the reasons we think. Well, he finds out when they're talking that she works at a place that does catalogs for community colleges and small businesses. They must use a lot of paper. I mean, at first we're like, is he attracted to her? No, he's just trying to make a huge paper sale. Yes. Jenna, there was a lot in deleted scenes of like, people just sort of chit chatting, trying to flirt, trying to meet people, make conversation. Well, Creed talks to Lynn. Oh, he tries to strike up conversation with her. You got to hear it. How old are you? Wait, let me guess. 30. No, no, no. 60. 34. Cool beans. Me too. Well, you were you born.
那个打扮得像安吉拉的女人，但原因和我们想象的不同。好吧，当他们谈话时，他发现她在一家为社区学院和小企业制作目录的公司工作。他们一定用了很多纸。我的意思是，起初我们在想，他是被她吸引了吗？不，他只是想做成一笔巨大的纸张生意。是的。珍娜，被删减的片段里有很多人们只是在闲聊、试图调情、试图认识人、进行对话的内容。好吧，克里德和琳谈了谈。哦，他试图和她搭讪。你得听听这个。你多大？等等，让我猜猜。30岁。不，不，不。60岁。34岁。酷。我也是。那你是在哪出生的。
Wow. I know. First of all, he leaves off with like, how old are you? Let me guess. And then he goes from 30 to 60. This is Creed trying to make small talk, guys. I remember I was in a bar once and a guy tried to flirt with me by asking me how much I weighed. And then he said, I bet I can guess. And then he picked me up without my consent and then set a number. Fellas, there's so much wrong with this. I hope we don't have to break it down for you. But like, don't do that. Yeah. All those things. Yeah. Don't say as you're pickup line. Let me guess your age or your weight. Yeah. Don't put your hands on a lady unless she invites you to. So many things. So many things. But you know who did spark some interest in Lynn?
哇。我知道。首先，他是以“你多大？让我猜猜”开场的。然后他从30岁直接跳到60岁。伙计们，这是克里德在试图闲聊。我记得我以前在一家酒吧里，有个家伙试图跟我调情，竟然问我有多重。然后他说，我打赌我能猜出来。接着他未经我同意就把我抱了起来，然后说了一个数字。小伙子们，这其中有太多不对劲的地方了。我希望我们不需要为你们逐一剖析。但总之，别那么做。是的。所有这些事情。是的。别把“让我猜猜你的年龄或体重”当作你的搭讪开场白。是的。除非女士邀请你，否则不要对她动手动脚。有太多不对劲了。有太多不对劲了。但你知道谁确实激起了琳的一些兴趣吗？
Ultimately was Kevin. I know. And he's very charming in his just nervousness and honesty and doesn't Brian kill it in the scene where he shows that she gave him her business card? Yes. It reminds me of that episode when they won their parking lot back from the five families. And he's like, sometimes you just need things to go your way. Yes. I mean, I'm getting goosebumps just thinking about it when he does that. Such a good actor. I know. Unfortunately, it looks like they're going to have to close down the party and Glove Girl never shows up. Michael doesn't want to leave. He wants to keep waiting it out and people stick around for a while. It's very sweet. Even Angela. Even Stanley. Yeah. Yeah.
最终是凯文。我知道。他凭借自己的那种紧张和诚实显得十分迷人，难道布莱恩在那个场景中没有大放异彩吗？当时他展示了她给了他她的名片。是的。这让我想起了那一集，当时他们从五大家族那里赢回了停车场。他说，有时候你只需要事情顺着你的心意发展。是的。我的意思是，仅仅一想到他那样做，我就会起鸡皮疙瘩。真是个好演员。我知道。不幸的是，看起来他们不得不关闭派对，而“手套女孩”始终没有出现。迈克尔不想离开。他想继续等待，大家也留下来了一会儿。这非常温馨。甚至连安吉拉也是。甚至连斯坦利也是。是的。是的。
And Oscars ultimately like, no, come on, Michael, it's time. Let's all walk out together. We got meal. Okay. Aiden M wrote in to say, why did Michael never get to find the lady who left her glove in the blood drive ban? It has driven me crazy, even though he ends up with Holly. And Diana P went on to say, why didn't this storyline continue? I asked Katie about it because I was curious. It just shows you how good of a job they did together in that scene that people wanted to see more of the blood drive girl and Michael. Well, the message boards after this episode aired were all for Glove Girl. And here's what Katie had to say. Oh, man, you guys. So here is the thing about my experience is that when I auditioned,
最后奥斯卡说，不，拜托，迈克尔，时间到了。让我们一起走出去吧。我们拿到了饭。好吧。艾登M写信来说，为什么迈克尔从来没有找到那个在献血车里留下手套的女士？这让我快要疯了，尽管他最终和霍莉在一起了。而黛安P接着说，为什么这个故事情节没有继续下去？我问了凯蒂关于这件事，因为我很好奇。这恰恰向你展示了他们在那个场景中配合得多么出色，以至于人们想要看到更多关于献血车女孩和迈克尔的故事。好吧，这一集播出后的讨论板全都在支持“手套女孩”。以下是凯蒂的说法。哦，天哪，伙计们。所以关于我的经历，情况是这样的，当我试镜时，
and it was with a caveat that it was a possible recurring character. And so all I wanted was to perform well and to impress and to be asked back. And it didn't happen. It didn't happen. And I'm sure they had their creative reasons. But oh boy, I wanted nothing more. But I'm happy with the time I got. That's for sure. So I will tell you story wise, why Glove Girl did not come back. It was not because we were not completely charmed by Katie and her performance because she crushed it. Clearly. Yes. Michael has a talking head and it's really written in this talking head. He says that this is the first time since Holly that he's even considered getting back into the dating Marina. Marina? The Marina.
这是附带条件的，即它可能是一个常驻角色。所以我要的只是表现出色、留下深刻印象并被再次邀请。但这并没有发生。并没有发生。我确信他们有他们的创作原因。但天哪，我别无所求。不过我对得到的这段时间很满意。那是肯定的。所以我来告诉你们从故事角度来看，“手套女孩”为什么没有回归。并不是因为我们没有完全被凯蒂和她的表演所迷住，因为她演得棒极了。显然如此。是的。迈克尔有一段独白，这段独白真的是写在这段独白里的。他说，这是自霍莉以来，他第一次甚至考虑重新回到约会圈。码头？码头。
Like Cupid's Sparrow. Yeah. And that was the story point of this episode was not to introduce a new love interest for Michael. They ultimately decided. They were toying with this idea. But really it was just for Michael to feel like he could connect with someone again. But ultimately they're going to keep him on this trajectory toward Holly. But because of this storyline, he's not going to be kind of as broken when he does finally reunite with her. Does that make sense? Yeah. No, he's hopeful. He's getting a little bit of his confidence back. Yes. And that's important. Yeah. Well, the whole gang is going to leave the building. And Jenna, I just want you guys to know when you watch us all exit, Mindy and I are just having a conversation. Yeah, I saw
就像丘比特的麻雀一样。是的。这一集的故事重点不是为迈克尔引入一个新的恋爱对象。他们最终决定。他们当时在琢磨这个想法。但实际上只是为了让迈克尔觉得他可以再次与某人建立连接。但最终他们会让他在走向霍莉的轨迹上继续前进。但因为有了这个故事情节，当他最终与她重聚时，他就不会那么崩溃了。这说得通吗？是的。不，他充满希望。他正在找回一点自信。是的。而这很重要。是的。好吧，全员都要离开大楼了。珍娜，我只想让你们大家知道，当你们看着我们所有人退场时，敏迪和我正在聊天。是的，我看到了
that. I'm gesturing to my hair. I don't know what we're talking about. Neither. You're very animated. Very animated. And then I feel like they sort of let us know that we're on camera because then I go back to Angela Martin and I do these little awkward waves goodbye. But everyone is very pleasant and nice to one another. Michael's Lonely Hearts Party was kind of a success. Yeah. I mean, they were all sort of lonely together. Yeah. This episode ends with a great tag. So funny. Found it very funny. Stanley goes into the blood mobile and he's got a little bandage on his arm. He's got a cotton ball with a little bit of medical tape and he says, I'm so sorry. I gave blood earlier and I'm still feeling a little woozy. Do you have a cookie?
那个。我在对我的头发比手画脚。我不知道我们在聊什么。我也不知道。你非常生动。非常生动。然后我觉得他们有点让我们知道我们在镜头前，因为随后我回到了安吉拉·马丁的状态，做出了这些尴尬的挥手道别。但每个人对彼此都非常愉快和友好。迈克尔的孤单的心派对算是一次成功。是的。我的意思是，他们都在一起显得有些孤独。是的。这一集以一个很棒的尾声结束。太搞笑了。我觉得非常搞笑。斯坦利走进献血车，他的手臂上贴着一小块绷带。他拿着一个带有少许医用胶带的棉球，说，非常抱歉。我早些时候献了血，现在还是觉得有点头晕。你们有饼干吗？
Can I have one of those cookies? Right. And she says, you know what? You have a cotton ball and medical tape, but we're using band-aids. Yeah. She's like, huh, weird. And behind him, Phyllis walks up. He's making a quick exit and he just goes band-aid. And she's like, damn it. And then Creed leaves the truck with his blood in a bag or someone else's. I'm not sure. To go where? To do what? I don't know. But this is what Dwight has been worried about the whole episode. I know. Where is Dwight? I don't know. Well, that was blood drive, everybody. That is blood drive, everyone. I'm going to go home. I'm going to put on different shoes. Cool off your feet. Don't put on any shoes. Just take shoes off. It's like 95 degrees out. I encourage you to get
我能吃一块那种饼干吗？对吧。然后她说，你知道吗？你拿的是棉球和医用胶带，但我们用的是创可贴。是的。她就像是，哈，真奇怪。在他身后，菲利斯走了过来。他正准备快速离开，直接说了一句“创可贴”。然后她说，该死。接着克里德带着他的血袋离开了卡车，或者别人的血袋。我不确定。去哪里？去做什么？我不知道。但这就是德怀特整集都在担心的事。我知道。德怀特在哪里？我不知道。好吧，这就是《献血车》，各位。这就是《献血车》，各位。我要回家了。我要换双鞋。让你的脚凉快点。别穿任何鞋了。外面有95度呢。我鼓励你们去买
a pair of flip flops. Yeah. And I guess I have to fix my hair. Well, you do have one guy that's going he's like at attention just in your bangs. I'm growing my bangs out. Oh, so it's a transition. They're a strange length. Mm-hmm. It was a summer thing. We're moving into fall. Yeah, you gotta have your fall hairdo. That's right. I'm moving into, I don't know what my fall hairdo is yet, but we're transitioning out of bangs right now. I can't wait to see what your fall hairdo is. Well, I know I'm going to get the truth from you. That's for sure. That's for sure. All right. Have a great week. I love you, lady. All right, guys. Have a great week. We'll see you later. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
一双人字拖。是的。我想我还得整理一下头发。好吧，你确实有一撮头发在竖着，就在你的刘海里。我在留长刘海。哦，所以这是一个过渡期。它们的长度很尴尬。嗯哼。这是夏天的风格。我们要迈向秋天了。是的，你得弄个秋季发型。没错。我正在迈向，我还不知道我的秋季发型是什么，但我们现在正在从刘海过渡出去。我等不及想看你的秋季发型了。好吧，我知道我会从你这里得到实话。那是肯定的。那是肯定的。好了。祝你们度过愉快的一周。我爱你，女士。好吧，伙计们。祝你们度过愉快的一周。我们回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·菲舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。有关Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码Office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。